until he and i broke up financially took
care of this man for that entire time
holy [ __ ] and i loved him so much that i
took on four jobs just to support him
you're [ __ ] while he was at home
playing video games you're [ __ ] nuts
like when i say i love heart i [ __ ]
love heart
and so many people give me a bad rap
they're like oh you broke up with him
because you got popping on the podcast
this and that
[ __ ] i was a sugar mom what are you
talking about that's
crazy but yeah like i working long hours
and working hard doesn't scare me what
scared me
in five [ __ ] four three two one sorry
everybody we're re-recording this
podcast real quick because
i [ __ ] this thing glitched and we
didn't get that whole story
but we have cat lee in that hey what's
up from the fighter and the kids
i [ __ ] hate when i do this so yeah in
the last two podcast i [ __ ] forgot to
hit record
and then i recorded two episodes with no
audio like two full episodes
episodes and i didn't [ __ ] hit the
record but wait so what did you do
you just re-recorded them no i trashed
it because like you can't catch
lightning back into you
you can't those two episodes were so
[ __ ] funny i was
uh pissed as hell because i just don't
like redoing things yeah but thank god i
caught that [ __ ] [ __ ] early yeah your
boy smart as [ __ ] man
well we were just getting into a
conversation real quick about
kat lee's upbringing and we found out
number one
just to kind of break it down again
because we're re-recording this yes uh
you grew up in san jose yeah and you
went to your parents
which which is so interesting too
because i feel like
you're vietnamese right yeah a lot of my
vietnamese homegirls they didn't really
have much tiger parents
yeah usually they don't mind were
different
well so okay so your parents wouldn't
let you
hang out with anybody i was not allowed
to have friends like acquaintances
as and classmates were as far as i could
like have a label on other people
outside of family
okay and i used to get my ass beat if my
mom thought i was on like [ __ ]
myspace tumblr zanga ass beat
wait did you do you have uh siblings
yeah i have one younger sister she's two
years younger and
a baby brother he's not really a baby
he's like 10 11 but he's my baby so
so did does he does he also have those
restrictions as well or is it not really
it's definitely loosened up i mean i'm
like the first daughter in an ethnic
family so i'm basically a mother
that's crazy dude because i can't
imagine my parents were pretty strict
too right yeah obviously i feel like in
asian families
the the boys are allowed to do more than
the girls because the girls are like the
damsel in distress
they always they're always worried about
somebody hurting you or something else
yeah but you're the oldest
you're the oldest in your family so
usually it's like the the younger sister
has the older brother that'll take care
yeah but now it's the other opposite way
yeah so for you like you never got to go
out much
and then you went from this to [ __ ]
only fans
bro here's the thing i joke about i joke
about this [ __ ]
so much with my friends but i'm like
straight up i am here because i used to
get my ass beat but i also was raised
with so much
love that i'm good at making this into a
business like i'm making money off of it
like i'm not
like i guess like i'm [ __ ] up enough
to want to do only fans but i'm not
[ __ ] up enough to
like i'm making a bag i'm doing it smart
i'm doing it the smart way so
for okay i've literally just watched a
dock on only fans recently the hulu one
yes yeah i just recently watched that
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] was
blowing my [ __ ] mind right it's
interesting watching it so when you have
someone who doesn't do your parents know
that you do an only fans
yeah my dad told me to do it your dad is
the [ __ ] biggest
[ __ ] i've ever okay here's the
thing here's the thing my daughter can't
go out have no friend no sex only friend
make money
okay i don't give a [ __ ] no more i mean
here's the thing that like i explained
it to so my mom
and most of the women on my family on my
mom's side
they were all coffee shop girls so like
i was a part of kind of that life of
like
hot girls dressing in skimpy outfits to
get to make money
because like that's just what you do and
for those of you who don't know what
like a
vietnamese coffee shop is it's a
starbucks hooters and strip club
wrapped into one it and it's just like
with a bunch of vietnamese [ __ ]
so i grew up around that and i saw
growing up that there were two types of
women who would work
these type of jobs one it's the women
who came in
to get a check and then
leave and then there's women who's there
to get a check so they can invest
in their future yeah so a lot of girls
who were
in there were usually the younger women
were students
students who needed money to kind of pay
their way through tuition
books and then there were women who were
there because they had family
that classic story i'm stripping for my
future stripper with a heart of gold
um and then there are people who uh came
to this country without
really any sort of skills don't really
speak the language but they found this
vietnamese coffee shop they're like okay
that's gonna help me support my family
send some of it back to vietnam and then
there were girls who like straight up
went there to get like a drug dealer
boyfriend yeah
who gangbang who will like buy him a
beamer and some christian louboutins
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just saw that at
the end of the day you hit a certain
point
where your physical appearance will only
get you so far
and so you need to get in cash out and
like get the [ __ ] out yeah you need to
use that time and that money wisely
because you're not it's not going to
last forever
and there are certain girls who used to
come into coffee shops thinking like
holy [ __ ] i made seven grand in a month
or i made 14 grand in a month and i'm
gonna spend on a weekend in vegas i'm
gonna buy all these bags i'm gonna go on
vacation
and then there are other women who were
like i'm gonna go and get my degree or
i'm gonna get my real estate license and
i'm going to parlay that into something
else
and so for me i knew i needed to get in
get a bag and get out
where did you even come up with the idea
of doing an only fan it was an inside
joke because everyone on fire in the kit
is perverted as [ __ ]
oh really awesome real [ __ ] um first and
foremost i'd like to say i
love you guys i love you don't come for
me
but the moment i came onto the podcast
the first few months
i was privated on everything i was very
very
cautious to be like i don't want to be
known i'm here as
a intern i'm trying to do like
production work because at usc
although i majored in theater there's a
big chunk of my work that i did
with production so i would be a part of
like putting on school plays but not
as an actor i would like be in the wood
shop like helping make sets
i would be helping the people who are
like
setting up lights and stuff like that
just trying to learn
every part of production in theater yeah
and i really liked being behind the
scenes
so when i came on to fighter and the kid
i was like okay i'm just gonna be like
another intern who doesn't really say
anything maybe once in a while
and from there when people heard my
voice like i have a deep ass voice for a
girl
i got a deep ass voice and i know this
so when they heard that i was
a girl with this deep voice and i used
to talk about how i
was powerlifting while i was in college
people that i was like
this really hefty butch
like yeah yeah yeah yeah and so the
moment like they turned a camera on to
me and people saw what i look like
they're like oh wait
this isn't a butch lesbian yeah like a
tiny asian girl and she's kind of cute
and from there people started very
quickly sexualizing me
really really early on i was very
cautious of trying to be as conservative
as possible i took down a bunch of posts
from my instagram page before i went on
private
just because i didn't want that type of
attention i wasn't quite ready for it
and when that happened a bunch of people
started asking me like
yo can i see your feet and at first i
was like
hold on a second what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right now
they went from they want us to see your
feet yeah because
here you ask any girl on social media
there's always requests to see their
feet
always people want to see your feet and
for some reason on my page there just
weren't any photos of me at the beach in
sandals or anything so they didn't know
what my feet looked like i brought it up
once on the show like oh what's the
weirdest dm you've ever gotten can't i'm
sure these savages have
sent you some uh real winners and i was
like well there's the standard like dick
pics but the weirdest one to me is
they want to see my feet and that became
a joke an inside joke where
that's very real though yeah that's very
real and i hid my feet for two years
like this girl was building her business
from day one
ain't nobody gonna see these things ever
ever that's why she's tucking them away
right now you gotta pay for that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
subscription's only ten dollars that's
[ __ ] fun but that's how it happened
what it was like it started off as a
joke and even people who weren't into
feet
just started building on this are you
are you only showing your feet on your
only fans like what
no it's like a regular only fan i don't
do nudes but it's like any import model
that you used to see back in the day who
used to wear like
lingerie or like wet t-shirt stuff like
that's what i do
i also take photos of my feet get the
[ __ ] out he started off as a female
[ __ ] as a joke
i [ __ ] respect you and i hate you so
[ __ ] much i get that
the power people don't here's the funny
thing too because i when i was watching
that hulu documentary
about only fans right and there was uh
a dude on there like he's a bodybuilder
yeah or what he was they trying to make
him out as gay in the beginning and then
they come down like he's straight up
he's straight but gay dudes jack off to
him
right but the weird thing is is like the
good for him
how much men lust after women is
it's such a smart thing to just make
money off of
yeah it's the it's crazy to me right
because
just from people wanting to see
something from you that they're not
privy to
makes them want to give you money yes
right because if a guy came out and it's
like listen
i'ma open this only fan you're going to
see my foreskin i know
nobody's paying to see my foreskin you
know what i mean they're like
hey we're good bro you know it doesn't
matter if women find you attractive or
whatever they're probably okay with it
but
the fact that sex sells for women so
much better and on top of that
you're not [ __ ] like dildoing
yourself or anything it's just
hey you're gonna get a little silhouette
a little wet t-shirt thing and that's
all you have to do
blows my [ __ ] mind and some people
are people are either
amazed or they're so angry that i've
been able to make the amount of money
that i have
without getting nude that is so
increased but they're like
yes i feel like that's even smarter
though right because
i feel like if you want a 100 nude
people are gonna wait for that time
where she's like they're like she's
gonna
eventually go nude and i'm just biting
my time right now yeah and that's what
they're [ __ ] waiting for yeah
that's crazy and you know what's crazy
about that too
on only fans i've made it a point to dm
everyone back so
when you dm me you're having a
conversation with me like i will send
you a selfie as proof like yo this is me
at [ __ ] olive garden right now
with my baby brother yeah yeah like
you're talking to me
i'm not a girl who like has an assistant
who's answering
on my behalf like this is me you're
talking to me while you wait to see if i
have nudes now we're in a conversation
about key lime pie for three months and
now we're homies
that's [ __ ] crazy now you just want
to support me that's really smart though
i mean
people actually do get to know you right
which is
something a lot of people don't really
do it's just so like i remember
so once i saw the only fans thing i
signed up for only fast not for myself
right okay but they'll you know stick
something yourself
there's like because i'm not trying to
like show my [ __ ] but i i went to only
fans
and then there's free only fans so you
click on the only fans you do it
and then there's like this automatic
response from somebody yeah it's like a
welcome message
it's a basic welcome message and so like
i wrote back i was like is this really
you question mark
and then it's like this very very
uh just pre-written type of thing and
i'm like
oh is this how people they get somebody
they kind of develop this personal
relationship but you're actually
responding
yeah i think at first it's easy for you
because
at the beginning of me doing only fancy
i got so many messages that it was kind
of hard to customize everything so i
would copy and paste like
hey thank you for subscribing i really
appreciate the support for the first
message and then once they
veer off into like an actual
conversation then that's when it got
more personal but i'm actually talking
to people
that's [ __ ] yes that must be pretty
tiring though right
yeah i mean it's kind of exhausting yeah
it definitely at the beginning i used to
answer like 200 messages every single
day by myself so i'd sit
on my couch for like two to three hours
and respond to everyone's dms go to
sleep
and that's what i would do day in and
day out because i wanted to build a good
foundation
yeah like i know like this is only
fantastic because it's
my feet or whatever but at the end the
day i never want to make somebody
feel like i'm trying to scam them out of
money because yeah i heard so many
horror stories before getting on to only
fans of
these girls like the bellathorn thing
where she got on and she said that she
was gonna do nudes
and then she didn't and it like [ __ ]
up the whole system for a bunch of girls
and now there's a cap of how much you
can tip and how much you can
give somebody and i was very cautious
of ever trying to over promise things or
say
things that ultimately were gonna i'm i
wasn't gonna deliver on i didn't want to
say like
oh you want to see me topless and then
it's like it's
covered up but then like i'm not wearing
a bra underneath this
were you because you went to usc for
theater were you trying to be an actress
uh originally i i was and i wasn't i
auditioned for
usc the theater program only because i
knew that was the only school i
probably could have gone into because
even though i had good grades i didn't
take the sats i didn't take the acts
like i
did the bare minimum to try to get into
college and in my head
i thought i needed a way to get out of
san jose if i don't leave now i'm never
gonna leave i'm gonna stay here for the
rest of my life
and i'm gonna hate it so that's what
happens to people in san jose sacramento
like yeah yeah there's definitely a lot
of time it's not a bad thing it's not a
bad thing at all you know i think for
your case because you live such a
sheltered life
yeah the that's like the weird thing
that i feel some parents kind of [ __ ] up
on right you try to protect your child
so much
they begin to resent you sometimes a
little bit and they want to get away
from you as far as possible
it happens a lot of these little church
girls who grew up like hyper catholic
hyper christian and the moment they
experienced some [ __ ] that's a little
devil in them
they [ __ ] love that [ __ ] they go off
they start [ __ ] sucking dick and
everything you know so for in your case
too do you feel like because
because of that pressure from your
parents and not being able to do that it
probably
pushed you a little further away to do
stuff that wasn't something that was in
their plans
yeah absolutely i only auditioned for
theater because it was the only thing
that i thought i could
possibly get in on i didn't really have
too much acting experience before that
like i used to do like little dance
performances in high school but i
i really didn't have a theater
background and so i came in
i did a monologue and i got into a bunch
of schools i was like oh [ __ ] this is
dope
i chose usc and while i was there i used
to get so bored and i was so lonely i
just like i had such a hard time making
friends because everyone
in the theater program either already
kind of had their own
group of friends or they felt so far
removed from
what i could relate to because there
were a lot of really rich kids whose
family had the money to send them to
like these art schools which is fine
it's just
i didn't really mesh well with them so i
mean i think college in general is like
that for a lot of people right like
absolutely
growing up in sacramento and stuff when
i even i went to ucr a lot of like
hello my brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by skillshare listen let
me cut
the chase you're like me you have
hobbies you have goals and a bunch of
things you want to learn and try but you
don't even know where to get the right
information or where to start
well you can search online for hours on
that [ __ ] but i'm telling you you
don't have to get skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning and guess what i'm using it too
there's a bunch of things to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives like
us because skillshare is about real
growth and it has such an amazing
creative community the course i'm
checking out right now
is youtube success script shoot and edit
by marcus brownlee one of my favorite
creators of all time
and though i've been doing it for a long
time i can always learn from people who
are doing it better than me
and like i said skillshare is a
community of amazing creatives so
remember explore your creativity at
skillshare.combrain and get a free
trial of premium membership at
skillshare.com
brain kids got went to ucr because they
either got a full ride because they
couldn't get that from the colleges they
wanted
yeah so like i grew up really poor and i
went to college and there was people
with money and i couldn't relate to a
lot of these people
yeah how they spent money how they
function the things that they said the
way that they moved was just different
like even on some regular [ __ ] they go
yeah
we're gonna go to [ __ ] uh the uk for
vacation i'm like what the [ __ ] is
vacation you know i don't get nobody can
you have a passport like when summer hit
i worked at my [ __ ] parents store and
that's what i did so like i could i
could see that to and theater kids by
the way they're [ __ ] weird
yeah that's amazing here kids are weird
like it's just
they're a different breed of people
uh and i have this crazy story
okay i hope this guy doesn't listen to
it because uh he's a good friend of mine
he means well but he's just one of those
hey man theater kids are weird dude he's
weird he's one of those like super
like and when i say rich like rich rich
like
old old money his like his dad owns a
part of the warriors
oh [ __ ] that's tight okay uh but he is
the nicest kid
just didn't do the right thing in this
particular moment we
we're doing a play called the octa rune
and it's uh
a modern-day take on the old slave play
in octoroon so it's like written from a
black man's perspective
of this old racist play and he makes it
so
there is a black guy who's in white face
a uh asian guy or indian guy in
uh in red face
and then a uh other person
in blackface okay to try to like play
like a twist on how people see other
ethnicities
yeah in this play and this guy he got
the role where he was supposed to play a
native american
and he had the role to wear the red face
and for this particular production we
were all very sensitive about
okay we got to do this right because at
the end of the day we're doing something
very
very very offensive like there's
somebody with black face someone with
white face somebody with red face
and so we got to do this right this guy
was just so um
what's that type of actor that like
tries to become the thing that they
oh he's very like method very method
one day he shows up to a class and
thank god it was a theater class in
character and he came
with red face on he pretends like he
speaks
like he doesn't understand modern
english in the middle
of a lecture goes up to the projector
starts touching it like he doesn't know
what technology is
water is [ __ ] out into the hall for
the rest of the duration of the class
and everyone's just looking around like
what is he doing and then he came back
like without the red face and just like
as if nothing happened he's like i'm
gonna get an a-plus for this he really
thought like he was killing him and he's
[ __ ]
such a nice guy and he means well but he
starts one of those things
in the middle of class i don't know what
is this guy doing and i was the only
other person in that production
in that particular class they all looked
at me i'm like i don't know what he's
doing
i'm so sorry there's just a lot of weird
kids are weird theater kids are weird
dude people in hollywood are really
weird
dude i'm not sure if i told this story
on the podcast but either way when i
first came
to to los angeles right i was being
introduced to people in the acting world
i never wanted to be an actor i don't
even know if i particularly thought
doing stand-up was
entertainment per se i just did stand up
because it made me happy
that's all that it was and i wanted to
be a big standing comic because making
people laugh was something that i
fed off of i enjoyed it a lot so when i
came to los angeles i don't know what
this city is
i don't know what it breeds i don't know
this this this city is different it's
different right
if you're not from here and you come
here it's a rude awakening dude
i was such i was not ready for this [ __ ]
so when i first came
to los angeles i had a meeting with this
dude that was a producer of a very
popular film right and it was a horror
film
i was like okay cool i'll meet this i
don't know what this is about jordan
peele
no absolutely not i love jordan but
this dude is a [ __ ] weirdo he lives
next to the
the mansion where the manson murders
happened right oh he's one of those guys
yeah and so he moved there specifically
because it's next to the manson murders
and so people believe where they were
that happened is
a portal to a gateway to like the
netherworld they truly believe that
stuff
i don't know what the [ __ ] this white
people [ __ ] is right i'm going
in right so we get to this house and
he's like
my manager's telling me that it's gonna
be a good thing for me to meet this
person i'm like cool
whatever we got in there because he's
friends with his life insurance dude and
he does life insurance for this guy
okay i walk in this guy comes in
and he goes he tells me to stop he goes
wait wait for a second
if before you walk into this house if
you feel a chill
go down your body that's just the native
american spirit that's wandering around
this house and i'm looking at him i'm
like
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me
what is your name oh my god he didn't
even introduce his name
he just told me about the dead native
american spirit that sounds like so long
and then as i walk in he starts showing
me these pictures he goes see that
this like a polaroid picture of a chair
that was shattered
he goes the native american ghost lifted
this chair and smashed it against that
wall and i have a picture of it he shows
me this polaroid
i'm like where the [ __ ] am i this guy is
[ __ ]
weird and as we're having a conversation
he has another lady come in which i
thought was his wife it wasn't it was
like his friend and she's a reiki so she
talks to spirits
i'm like this is the most [ __ ] la
thing i've ever been to in my life
and he invited us and i thought it was
dinner and [ __ ] it wasn't dinners it was
like a plate of crackers and cheese i'm
like
[ __ ] this thing i was like yeah [ __ ]
whatever that [ __ ] is and i'm sitting
there
and then i have to have a conversation
with this other guy is this white dude
blonde hair blue eyes [ __ ] sweater
sweater around his neck
and he's over here talking about how
where he's traveled you know what he's
doing and i'm not a very nice person at
this point i have a very short temper
so i'm looking at this dude and this
guy's talking about where he's been and
my manager can tell i'm getting really
irritated yeah because he's just like
trying to stun
and so i'm like kind of goading this
dude on i'm like oh where else have you
been he goes
i've been to africa i've been over here
i was like germany he was like you've
been to germany
he goes yeah i was like what's that he
goes it's a country i was like
a country yeah like he's like yeah it's
like it's like
not here it's like have you traveled i
was like traveled what's that
you can tell this guy's getting [ __ ]
pissed and he goes well
he goes anyways i went to oktoberfest
out and i was like oktoberfest
i was like where's that he goes in
germany i'm like huh
you just feel my manager kicking me in
the [ __ ] leg like stop stop stop
making fun of him but this guy's being a
little [ __ ] dick
we go downstairs and i kid you [ __ ]
not he opens up this door
he goes david i want you to walk into
the earth room
and i'm like bro what are you talking
about walk into the earth room
there are spirits inside there and when
you walk in you're going to be
overwhelmed
we open this door and it's it's like in
the hollywood hills so you see this door
that opens up
and it's just a mound of dirt so it's a
part of the foundation to the house
it's dirt i walk in it's just a cold ass
room and i walk out he goes did you feel
that no he goes let me go inside he goes
into the earth room and he goes
oh the spirits the spirits are talking
to me and he starts freaking the [ __ ]
out
i'm mortified right now what the [ __ ] is
going
on and so we're trying to wrap this [ __ ]
up i go outside the reiki comes up to me
and she goes
it was nice meeting you david she hugs
me five minutes straight
doesn't let me go and i'm sitting here
staring at my manager pissed beyond
belief
because she's hugging me and she's like
doing this chan rubbing my [ __ ] back
like is this [ __ ] trying to have a
[ __ ] threesome get the [ __ ] off me i
think that's assault david
i think it was sexually harassing me i
think she you were sexually
harassed i think so too this is my first
experience in los angeles
yeah and i i didn't know what was going
on this city
breeds very weird people and he has
money and i think a lot of people wanted
to be his friend
because he has money yeah so like for me
i don't really function like that so i
was just like yo get the [ __ ] off me get
get me the [ __ ] out of here from that
point on i said when it comes to
meetings you take the meetings i don't
want to be there
you [ __ ] figure it out because i'm
going to sit there make fun of somebody
else and i'm going to freak out when
this happens you know
yeah i mean i don't know how your
experience is in like the the podcast
like
comedy world because that's a whole
world that other people don't even know
about yeah it's
a crazy world i think the first real bit
of like crazy la stories i got was
a few weeks after i had got the job at
fighter and the kid i got a second job
at
a apartment building i just graduated
from college so i was like i need to
make money and be able to pay
la rent so i picked up a second job and
while i was there it's
the type of place where a one bedroom
goes
for at least six seven thousand dollars
and like this like one bedroom isn't a
very big one bedroom
either you get like maybe 600 square
feet for
like six seven grand and it's in west
hollywood super bougie
it's pretty but not that pretty you get
a
house car driver in a rolls-royce or a
maybach who will drive you around town
like it's that type of place
like la hollywood bougie-ass
people this building has nothing
but [ __ ] crackheads in it really not
actual krakens but like actually you
know what yeah some crackheads
yeah but they just it was a bunch of
rich people with this
la mentality of like they they have this
very
specific idea of what they should be
doing
who they should like what they should
look like what
they should act like and there was this
guy who used to
for like the life of me i couldn't
understand very high power
lawyer in hollywood go and he would
remodel
his unit his two-bedroom unit that he
did not own
but he lived in for two years he just
wanted to keep busy so much and he loved
interior design he hated his law job but
it
financed his ability to interior
decorate this apartment that he does not
own
and he put marble walls everywhere what
the [ __ ] he redid the entire structure
of
his two-bedroom apartment so everything
is marble
and he would change the type of marble
it was every three four months
and he'd always have construction
workers coming in and out of the
building that he does not own
so he could have this like beautiful
like eccentric
beautiful apartment he didn't want a
house he would be up
all hours of the day like three in the
morning security guards
who stayed there overnight would see him
come in and out like smoking bringing
people
in his unit and then out of his unit
like we think it was just like a bunch
of his like weird friends coming in
his assistant used to bother us like
crazy because i was working the front
desk
and you come in with these stupid
demands like oh we need a carpenter
today and i was like okay let me call
and see he's like no no in 20 minutes
and
for those 20 minutes he'll go upstairs
and call me every two minutes to see
where i'm at with this
task and you would come downstairs and
you would then when you left you would
ask your co-workers for your phone
number to see where you went on that
topic and so like i had people calling
me
outside of work like who the [ __ ] is
this how did you get my number yeah like
what the hell is going on
and people walking in and out of the
unit like oh i'm here for a fitting
and they have nothing but like nibble
tassels on what and like
big time hollywood producers coming in
and out
drunk just like crashing their car at
three in the morning every single week
and we're like well we have to give him
his car keys because
dude when people think that's funny they
do some of the weirdest things man like
it's almost like and i find this out a
lot with people who
kind of grew up with money because their
their
idea of what a good time is starts
very small and i had a conversation with
on this podcast recently
about people who kind of grow up with
nothing they feel this experience of
coming up
right some of our favorite experiences
that we have especially
for me anyways because i grew up very
poor is these small little victories
right
well these victories for people who are
already rich it's kind of already a
given
so their level of experience stressful
is so high for that's already [ __ ]
high so that's why there's drugs there's
people who are doing crazy [ __ ]
i mean whenever you ever seen like it's
very rare that you see a disney kid that
turned out really well
yeah because they're given the [ __ ]
world even somebody like justin bieber
right
yeah i'm pretty sure when you see his
first he's a youtuber people forget that
yeah he was on youtube and now she found
him off that
yeah it was like brian mcknight usher
they found this kid and he was a gem he
was a
youtuber he is the classic example of a
youtube making something bigger
well he was given everything he has yes
men around him everywhere and he goes up
and then you see him go through his drug
issues uh his his personal issues being
put out there
dude i know somebody who used to uh
uh work for an agency that had to get
him to sign off certain things
um so he could travel internationally
his fool would have my friend
um sit there and because he was like on
his christ tip right like justin
bieber's christ tip
he would have people come in and she
would just need a signature from him
and she wouldn't uh do
basically he's like you know he's trying
to hit on her or whatever right and
she would have to sit there for hours
because he doesn't want to sign it
so she would sit there for six seven
hours waiting for him to sign something
and then he would bring some random girl
in
bring her upstairs and she told me that
this fool
would be upstairs chanting bible verses
to this girl before they [ __ ]
like have you like he she said that no
he's
asking her have you accepted this have
you accepted god as your lord and savior
right and she would say yes or something
and then they would [ __ ]
will you accept this dick exactly i'm
like yo
people are [ __ ] weird dude that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah everybody has these
weird stories of these like celebrities
and they have to be real
yeah they ellie just breeds different
type of like weird rich people
yeah it's really really odd i i don't
think i've ever
met someone from l.a who's kind of
in the i guess like la hollywood scene
that's like of sound
like mind yeah and you know everyone's
kind of wonky in one way or another yeah
people get caught up in
in some [ __ ] too because the the the
standard of what normal is is based on
the group that you're around
right yeah so absolutely i like i i see
a lot of these dudes where i ask them
who your closest friends is people that
they met within the first two three
years
like i still have the same best friend
since high school i still have the same
friends of sacramento and i have really
close friends here
my circle's actually very tight and very
small but a lot of people that i meet
here they don't have that tight circle
which is understandable too like
sometimes like i don't know where you
came from it probably wasn't that great
so
i get it but for me too like one of the
the things that i find weary about
somebody is when they can't find a
strong stable of human beings around
them
yeah because typically what happens is
that if if you have to be uh somebody
who hops from group to group
usually you're probably the issue
compared to everybody else
typically not saying that some i mean
obviously we've had people who grew up
in bad areas where i you don't want to
be friends with them anymore
but now i'm a little bit cautious about
people who can't find a stable group of
people
because they're so used to going in and
out there's a loyalty issue too in this
city like there's no loyalty
yeah like once you're done it's a lot of
times you hang out with someone up until
they can't do anything for you anymore
and then you flip oh 100
and that makes me sad too it's very
transactional i i've had that happen
like once in the city and it doesn't
happen again
because like i just like i told the
story to where this guy
he he's a habitual [ __ ] uh lighter
ladder climber right yeah he gets what
he wants he goes on to somebody else he
goes on to somebody else
but that [ __ ] runs out too because after
a while people pick up on that [ __ ]
and also too when you can't when you
have no skill set for yourself
and your skill set is just mooching off
of somebody else
that [ __ ] runs out yeah it always runs
out for people who want to be in
entertainment
that never [ __ ] works in the long run
because people get tired of that [ __ ]
they're going to move on from you you
have nothing to offer and they'll use
you just like you try to use them
yeah and it's it's it's it's something
that's very repetitive in this city
and i've uh i've been very careful about
who i select around me
and even now like everything is always
going to be based on fun
like if if i'm not having fun with you
i'm not going to work with you
because i got to see your [ __ ] face
all the time yeah you know money runs
out like my mom is very particular about
that like
there was a certain point where i was
working so hard where
money was abundant but i wasn't very
happy
so that's the part where i'm learning to
balance that a lot
because at the end of the day when i
look at other people who have
less less than me and they're happier
than me that i have something missing
here
i'm not i'm not i'm not functioning
right here right why the [ __ ] is it that
i could have all this material wealth
but they're the ones smiling all the
time and i'm over here [ __ ] miserable
yeah
that's off it doesn't make any sense
there's people i know who live in hawaii
they have to work like two three jobs to
get by sometimes and they're the
happiest people i've ever seen
so where where am i [ __ ] up right now
that i feel like i have to have more
things to make me happier and i figured
out that's not for me and i think people
like
me and joe joe figure that out you see
joe joe's [ __ ] nuts first of all i
[ __ ] love the energy that joe has i
don't know what it is he's
such a free spirit and he's so weird and
eccentric but like pure
let me tell you that makes any sense you
want to talk about free joe went to
a [ __ ] uh uh vietnam and he ate eight
out of hooker's [ __ ]
wait
it was a story he told on the podcast
god bless him i knew i liked him
this [ __ ] was like let me do
your job for you [ __ ] oh my god
this dude cracks me the [ __ ] up but even
for him too like he had to figure out
what makes him happy he and i both went
through a period where
we were trying to work so hard is we
said to ourselves that we are going to
work so
[ __ ] hard right now that later on
then we can be happy
yeah we found out we could be happy now
and still continue to work
like he lives he's like this close to
living off the [ __ ] grid
yeah right and you know we he looks like
it let's just say that
he looks like he's he was a samurai for
years and he traveled time and then he's
like trying to figure out
have you heard that story of that uh
japanese guy stuck in a cave who didn't
know the war was over and he lived there
for
no 15 years okay so i'm going to butcher
the story
but there was a man during uh
the war i forgot which one terrible
storytelling
but basically he hid his a war
yeah a war with japan yeah um but it was
a japanese man who
hid in a cave because he thought the
enemies were gonna get him
years down the line he stayed in this
cave for about like 10 to 15 years
like for well over a decade
when somebody came and found this odd
old
like man hair disheveled looks like
[ __ ]
asian tarzan they asked him what are you
doing and he tried to kill those guys
because they thought he thought they
were the enemies yeah and he didn't know
the war was over
that's what i get from joe what the [ __ ]
that's what i get from joe
joe a man who doesn't know the war is
over joe has figured out the key to his
happiness right
and it's a beautiful thing though like
you can tell when you see him
yeah man and we went through a a very i
mean
imagine joe being as a free spirit as he
is right yeah
and for people who are newly jojitsuka
is a part of
this company called jk news um i'm only
saying this is people who don't know
sometimes
but uh we both they built a really large
company and albeit
it was a lot of work and i think the the
thing that we didn't think about is that
when we build this company and we have
people who are employees who are under
us
we are now responsible for their
livelihood and that was a lot of
pressure
yeah um to be in a position where we
have to worry whether they're gonna get
a next meal or not was
a pressure that i felt like i couldn't
really handle that's why i function by
myself
because of my anxiety like i'm more
worried about this person's paycheck
than i am about my own well-being
because i don't want to fail them and
that's that was the same thing for them
too they're like well we built this
company
and we were thinking about building it
out like we spent a [ __ ] ton of money on
these commercial offices and then we go
i don't think i like this like i i made
my
i made a desk job for myself how the
[ __ ] did i do youtube and then make a
desk job which is something that i never
wanted to do
and i started doing like these scheduled
things and i figured out that i had to
figure
for both of us we had to figure out a
way where we could do the work but still
have our fun now
because at the end of the day like i'm
33 now well let's say i want to work
hard for 10 years then i'm 43 then i get
to have fun
[ __ ] that dude life is short i want to
have fun and be able to do both and it's
a matter of me figuring out
how much do i need of these material
things and i don't really need much i
grew up as a christian boy like
and even within that religion it's like
yo you don't need material things to be
happy
so when we started making a lot of money
i started buying everything that i
wanted like
yeah i'm pretty sure brendan's shop has
a huge kit collection i guarantee you
five years ago my my kit collection
[ __ ] on his like
it was every [ __ ] shoe you could
[ __ ] imagine i had
and so who's your shoe plug i didn't
have a book i just spent that money he
didn't find oh
yeah i didn't give a [ __ ] okay so
because i grew up because i wanted
everything i didn't have when i was a
kid
so that was my basis of happiness i
bought this thing
i walked away and i said this is going
to make me happy and it never does and i
was like no
i got to buy another shoe put it on and
that's how it happens it's a slippery
slope then you have la
yeah and then you have l.a i would i'm
like this dude that has a bunch of shoes
i never wear them never put them on my
feet
so now i have this thing where it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] how much the shoe is
worth if i [ __ ] with it i'll buy it but
i'll wear it
all the time yeah so now my shoe
collection is down to like maybe 20
shoes now so i don't have
any of those shoes anymore and so that
was what we figured out we enjoy
life experiences we enjoy traveling i
enjoy time with people now
yeah this is what this podcast is i
enjoy talking to new people i enjoy
hearing your story
because this is the stuff that i'm going
to remember for the rest of my life yeah
i'm not going to remember the shoe that
i [ __ ] bought
i'm not gonna remember [ __ ] i don't
know like uh
the car that i buy any of this stuff is
i'm gonna forget about it
because once that value goes away you're
gonna try to replace it with something
new
yeah but that's why people have kids
that's why people
build these things because they want to
build it with the people around them
because imagine if i was
successful by myself how lonely is that
how lonely is that
dude here's the thing i i felt that
recently because i was at that same
place where i was working as hard as i
could
and at one point i was juggling four
jobs damn
i was juggling four jobs granted there
was there were other circumstances at
play
like whatever okay
if you know my ex-boyfriend please don't
say anything to him he's a good guy
nice guy but uh he went through a rough
patch and
when he moved to la it was very sudden
and very abrupt yeah i was here i had
just graduated from usc and i was
starting to
kind of get into my like adulthood i got
my first
like adult job at a podcast and i was on
the way to
do an interview with another one when he
said
i need to move out of where i'm at now
in san jose he and i were high school
sweethearts i was with this guy for a
damn near 10 years
whoa like 14 to 23 almost 24. like
high school sweetheart i thought i was
going to spend the rest of my life with
this man i loved him
more than i think i've lost and none
and uh because because we've been
together for so long
it didn't shock me when he was like oh
like can i move in with you because i
had been with him
at that point for like six years already
i'm like yeah sure move in
so he came and he moved in with me and
about a month
before he moved in with me he had gotten
a puppy
and i just moved out of the old
apartment i was at
that my parents used to pay for and so
now i'm living in basically a closet in
burbank wears
500 square feet studio apartment with
all
of the furniture that i had from a like
700 square foot apartment
so everything's like it looked like a
hoarding situation and now i have his
stuff too
and he was going through some [ __ ] where
he was having a hard time
making money and i supported him from
the day he not even the day i would say
like
six months before that up until he and i
broke up financially took care of this
man for that entire
time holy [ __ ] and i loved him so much
that i took on four jobs just to support
him
you're [ __ ] while he was at home
playing video games you're [ __ ] nuts
like when i say i love heart i [ __ ]
love heart
and so many people give me a bad rap
they're like oh you broke up with him
because you got popping on the podcast
this and that
[ __ ] i was a sugar mom what are you
talking about that's
crazy but yeah like i working long hours
and working hard doesn't scare me what
scared me was like the
thought of like losing somebody that i
loved so i was willing to work
all these jobs and i was having no fun i
had no friends i had no
sort of like sense of stability and when
he and i ended up
breaking up it was like the i was out of
that relationship
mentally for i'd say about eight months
because i was just working the entire
time i never saw him
holy [ __ ] and i got to a place where i
was like damn i'm not having fun
and i am in my early 20s
i'm working my dream job at a podcast i
don't even care that i'm working these
other jobs but i'm just not [ __ ]
happy like why am i not happy now
and so i started telling myself maybe if
you just keep
working your ass off working your ass
off now
later on it'll pay off and you can be
happy then i don't know when it is but
it'll be
later and once you have a certain amount
of money in your
bank account you and him will be good
again it'll be like none of this ever
happened it'd be a funny little
story and so fast forward a year and a
half
in all that hard work started to pay off
and i
got taken on full time at the podcast so
now i'm just podcasting full-time
and i am making more money than i have
made with those
past like three other jobs combined yeah
and i'm so happy i'm in this brand new
apartment it's like a nice
it's not like that bougie but in
comparison to the 500
square foot it's a close up it feels
good yeah it was amazing and then
he and i just sat down one day while we
were settling into this new apartment i
was like
it didn't fix anything happy i'm looking
around and i'm like i should be happy
everything should be the same
and it wasn't until like he and i broke
up and i had a real conversation about
with him like yo i love you but in
four months if this keeps going on i'm
gonna hate you like i know that we gotta
split up
or i'm gonna hate you and resent you for
years to come like i don't want it to
come to that i've been with you forever
you're like my best friend
but we need to split ways and so we
broke up didn't end the best
but then after that i was alone for a
while and suddenly
like after the whole breakup happened
and i
became okay with being alone for the
first time since i was 14. oh [ __ ]
that's right i was like yeah the first
like
two months it was [ __ ] rough i'm
sorry this woman leaves me i'm dead
oh my god i don't i wouldn't know what
to do i don't know how to talk to women
anymore
that's why i i thought i was so lucky
because i was like okay i got out of
this while i was 24. imagine if this
happened and i was like 37. oh you'd be
[ __ ] like
i'd be [ __ ] i have no social stuff
like if i come i wouldn't know what to
do like i came up with a girl i'm like
hey like a nice [ __ ]
i was like that's a nice [ __ ] like
what'd you say i don't know i don't know
what i'm doing i'm sorry
yeah but like the moment i was alone i
and i finally got to breathe i was like
okay i can start kind of rebuilding
a foundation of what makes me happy
isn't that crazy though because
you've been with somebody so long a lot
of your moves that you make
isn't about yourself it's about you and
them right and so it's like
especially in your case because you took
on such a
i honestly like a mother responsibility
everything that you were doing was to
was for this guy yeah and then now
you're in a position where it's like
i don't this is not my responsibility
now i have to focus on my
focus on cat and now you're just in this
new world where you have to learn how to
adapt to this because it wasn't how it
was before
and it's so weird like because i i had
been with him since i was 14 like i
never really had a dating
like wild party girl dating stage i was
i went from being super sheltered
with this boyfriend to like now i'm
single
and i'm 24. did he feel like you were
leaving him because of your success
no he knew it wasn't that i straight up
told him like
i need you to pull more weight in and if
and he started to very very slowly but
only when
i had to ask him which was one of those
things where he's like
it's not attractive to have to ask your
significant other
like i need you to financially bring
bring in your weight yeah when like i
know that i am making enough money to
take care of both of us comfortably now
but i shouldn't have to ask you yeah
there's no i mean
where's his pride in as a human being
yeah like i'm not saying that let's say
like my fiance makes more than me
i'm not going to stop working i'm going
to still do what i do and have a passion
about what i do
yeah and it sucks for you when you're
such a motivated human being you're
finding things
every day to kind of level up and your
partner isn't doing the same
it brings you down yeah it happens in
your personal friendships too
right absolutely with friendships all
the time and you're just like ah this is
a [ __ ] bummer yeah
when you see the first beginnings of it
you're like [ __ ] i hope i'm proven wrong
but
i know how this ends and i say it all
the time it's it's not that
something's wrong with the the people
that we have around us it's like we
could still be acquaintances but the
more i start to
try to be better and you start to we're
on different paths we're on different
paths
we're still close we're still homies but
now we have less and less to talk about
because every time we come back we have
a conversation it's about what i'm doing
and i ask you what you're doing you go
oh same [ __ ]
yeah then the conversation dies we
relate less and that sucks more on a
relationship level too like i've always
wanted to be with somebody who was
independent and has goals of their own
yeah and um we i talked about it with my
fiance and she opened up on this podcast
talking about how
she was in a position where she thought
that she didn't realize it but
everything she was doing was
for me she goes i'm happy when david's
happy and i'm like no no no no you need
to be happy
on your own yeah you might your
happiness shouldn't be dictated by how i
feel
it should be how you feel and so she
found that out going through therapy
and i think that's the part where people
get lost sometimes in their
relationships
like your personal happiness is
dependent on your partner and that's not
fair
and for him he was probably okay kind of
cruising and he probably knew things
were going bad
yeah but you know you were paying for
everything i think also didn't
help like i don't think it was him
necessarily trying to play victim but
that i would coddle him too because i
would feel bad like oh like
i kind of put him in this position where
like i'm making the money he came to la
to be with me
so like i should like suddenly i felt
like responsibility and then that's
where resentment happened
yeah i mean that's a lot to [ __ ] deal
with though i couldn't imagine being in
a 10-year relationship
and then trying to make moves after like
that's that's the i feel it's a little
easier for girls though
oh it's definitely easier yeah you know
there's always a line when you're
waiting for a girl it's like okay but
for a guy sometimes a girl has a back up
like a runner-up
miss congeniality exactly once these
guys are like yo [ __ ] especially in his
case you were the sugar mama so now he's
just
out on his ass yeah he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] to do but that's that's the
position that he put himself in
yeah which kind of sucks like that's
[ __ ] unattractive unattractive
oh my god did that did that affect like
your guys's sex life a lot
yes absolutely here's the thing i
have such and again i think it's because
i have strict tiger parents and i was
beaten a lot as a child i had
such a high [ __ ] libido it's insane
and so like the moment when i stopped
wanting sex is like oh something's wrong
oh
but i always blamed it on my birth
control it's like oh maybe it's just
like hormones this and that i
switched so many birth controls it was
on the birth control so you didn't think
that it was maybe this
i'd say like the last year and a half of
our relationship that's when it clicked
i was like it's not the birth control
oh my god that's [ __ ] crazy yeah it
was one of those things where i would
like we would have sex and it'd be
enjoyable but it's always out of like i
had a clock in my head like oh i haven't
done it in a while
yeah ah and so it wasn't enjoyable
and then the moment he and i broke up
i started having sex normally i was like
oh here it is
oh really yeah my boyfriend used to do
porn what the [ __ ]
that's dude your [ __ ] story's so
weird i'm sorry like
you went from this this is why you don't
beat your kids
that's why you don't [ __ ] shelter
them too hard they're gonna figure out
what's on the other side
[ __ ] man to be fair my parents love them
though that's [ __ ] fun he's a former
porn how long do you do porn for
uh i want to say about a year maybe
he was dating a a very well-known porn
star
and then uh when she stopped getting the
way it was explained to me like
when she stopped wanting to do normal
porn and it kind of got into like the
only fans territory she's like oh i can
do this with
whoever i want now now that i'm my own
boss yeah i would rather just do it with
my boyfriend
and that's how he got into porn and then
he and her
broke up and they start they still did
porn for a little bit to make money
during the pandemic
but once they broke up i actually met
him on the podcast
and he and i started dating shortly
after and i told him like hey
i know you're like i've always known
that you've done porn because you're
boys with my boss and i've always known
of you but like now that we're dating
it's a little different
as much as i like you i am not
secure enough to be okay with having a
partner who does porn actively right now
oh that's like i don't care that you
i don't care that you've done porn like
that is the last of the best
yeah yeah but like with me right now i
just know that i am very territorial
and i will not feel comfortable with you
doing porn let alone porn with your
ex-girlfriend
so i'm just gonna have to cut this off
here i try to break up with him multiple
times
and he eventually i think like the
second
week where i was like yeah i'm still not
trying to like talk to you
hang out with you like we're not dating
anymore he just kind of slowly stopped
doing porn
and he never told me okay like he and i
would hang out and we would hook up and
i'd always say like oh this is the last
time but it wasn't
yeah and slowly over time i just thought
like he hasn't done any porn
yeah and i asked him he's like yeah i
stopped doing porn because you didn't
want to date me
oh wow i was like oh wow and he was like
he had no income at that point in time
he was during the pandemic he was like
squatting in his apartment
in costa mesa to be with me what the
[ __ ] that's very
good dedication dude yeah that's nuts
man like i
i actually brought somebody on this
podcast who was in the porn world
and this [ __ ] tried to do some crazy
like i i
i already crazy i already got a [ __ ]
i still have the clip
i i have the podcast in my in my [ __ ]
yeah
um because so this this this young lady
basically i i wanted to ask her about
her in the porn industry
because it's an asian girl and i'm
always so curious about how
asian women get into porn specifically
because of
uh that tiger asian parent type of stuff
right yeah and so
like i wanted to see what that story is
in that transition and
it went from this weird podcast where
she was talking about
like her really personal stuff like
her ex-boyfriend coming in doing crazy
[ __ ] and all this other stuff
and i started getting a little
uncomfortable and i actually cut the
podcast off a little earlier
yeah and then she starts bawling and
crying
talking about her personal issues and
the reason why
i was like cool well i've recorded this
in the office you
the podcast is here uh i'm not gonna get
caught up on some [ __ ]
because she's gonna try to spin some
kind of crazy story yeah
so what i did was all right cool i'm
gonna call you an uber so i have it on
my thing that i called you an uber
it's time when we did the podcast in
case she tries to say
anything right and i i was creeped the
[ __ ] out like i
literally i'm getting goosebumps right
now because i felt like she was trying
to do some [ __ ]
yeah later on she starts messaging all
my friends saying like
is it normal to be on the podcast where
somebody is like trying to pressure you
to tell you stories
that you don't want to tell like this is
your friend david's doing
i'm like [ __ ] i have the recorded
podcast like yeah what are you talking
about
i have proof yeah you know that right
what are you [ __ ] talking about yeah
and so she was messaging everybody that
i know
it was during the whole me too thing so
she was trying to export me i'm like
[ __ ] i'm the most respectful
you'll never get the story i'm the most
respectful [ __ ] you'll ever meet
and so i got freaked out i'm like yo and
here's the thing too like i understand
her story in her case because she's
probably been through
so much [ __ ] drama yeah right i don't
know what's going on about that
because i don't know anything about the
porn but when i talked to her and i
started talking to other people
i started hearing their stories about
like where they came from before they
went to the porn industry yeah and i'm
like damn these girls are damaged dude
like there's some
something [ __ ] off about some of
these people and i got scared
yeah and that at that point i was like
thank god i had my podcast at another
space
where um they can't say i brought them
into my home
that's why i moved to an office because
i was scared of people because i was
scared people were going to do that now
i
now i only bring people on this podcast
that i at least know or we have a small
community with yeah because i'm not
having people trying to [ __ ] me over
like it's definitely scary because you
never
with doing something like this you never
know what someone can say
or do you really don't and yeah you like
to give people the benefit of the doubt
but when you
hear and see so many stories time and
time again where people
take advantage of a movement you're like
oh [ __ ]
and that's not to take away from like
that either yeah and i got freaked out i
was like i can't believe somebody's
trying to pull this [ __ ]
on me like me i was like me
because she she actually approached me
as a
as a fan of mine oh and so i was like oh
dope
so she hit you up yeah i didn't know
what she did but she took
a photo with me at a at a send foods
event
yeah and um this this random girl
and then a buddy of mine was like dude
that's a porn star
i was like what do you mean he's like
that girl is a porn star i was like how
do you know that he goes did i jack off
her to her all the time
i was like okay i get it and so i was
like oh cool it'd be like oh i know yeah
i was like yeah bro you don't have to
say you're [ __ ] your tech smells
funny
i brought her on and then lo and behold
this woman tried to go all [ __ ] wow
me too on my ass over nothing i'm like
bro it was a podcast i asked you about
your industry
and then she tried to spin and i was
like but that's not going to make sense
because the podcast recorded
like how what were you going to do i
would just release the podcast and yeah
that's it
like the full unedited footage and then
suddenly everyone knows that you're a
liar and then she kept messaging me over
and over she wanted to come back on the
podcast he goes
i want to redo it i'm like i will never
speak to you ever again
are you out of your mind but that's she
is out of her [ __ ] mind
and i think she actually quit uh the
industry because she has like some
mental issues that she has to deal with
and then her friend i she said can i
bring my friend too i was like yeah of
course you could bring your friend
because i want her to feel comfortable
yeah and then her friend tried to come
back on my podcast i'm like
none of you are allowed back on here you
[ __ ] crazy people dude
like i i don't [ __ ] with you that's why
from here or not
i don't know you you're not coming on
this podcast yeah i'm scared dude yeah
i'm super scared it's a scary time in a
scary place
was it uh intimidating for you uh well
he only did porn with his uh girlfriend
though right yeah
i think well the way he was always
introduced to me
was almost like a myth like a
mythological creature
because the whole thing when i got onto
the podcast i always heard that they
have a friend
named stevie blue eyes and he is a guy
who
went to prison for nine years uh because
he was a federal prison because he got
uh caught on
like a conspiracy to distribute or
something okay he was like a part of
like some uh
no no drug dealing like mafia [ __ ] okay
uh
nothing violent that i know of and we'll
fight you'll figure that later
uh but he's the nicest guy ever he's
like a golden retriever who was in the
pound
yeah yeah yeah like my description of
him and they would tell
people like oh yeah he had cancer when
he was a kid he thought he was dying
and he uh was in prison for drugs and
now
he's doing porn and i was like who the
[ __ ] is this kid
who is just so weird and i had never met
him in my
two like two and a half years of working
there and one day
he just randomly came in because he was
in town he was living in vegas at the
time but he came in town for his
birthday
celebrating with my bosses and some of
his friends
he was hungover came into the podcast
the day after his birthday
and that's how i met him and i was like
oh hi and i gave him this handshake that
like now he's super angry about because
he wanted
he he said that he wanted a hug and he
thought that like he and i were already
friends because we were like in the
podcast world
but i want to shake his hand because i'm
like i don't [ __ ] know you yeah yeah
yeah you're like some [ __ ] boy
like [ __ ] porn stars and goes to prison
forever no
uh we did the whole podcast and they
always talk about his dick
always and this was the thing
that happened even before he started
doing porn they talked about how big his
dick is
holy [ __ ] yeah and they used to like
show everyone photos of his dick
which is like weird why do you have your
boys [ __ ] dick pic that's why people
[ __ ] baby
but that's white people [ __ ] yeah great
culture i'm not
judging or anything i'm a part of it now
i'm judging the [ __ ] out of that show
you guys
um and he and i started dating
shortly after that and at the time i
wanted nothing to do with him because i
thought he was still
dating his ex because i knew he was
still doing porn and he had
he started telling me all these super
personal details of his life
and he was like oh by the way like i
don't have a girlfriend and i was like
why are you telling me that i was like
i thought he was what's up and he's like
oh because i like you
i was like oh what yeah okay i guess
whatever and i wanted nothing to do with
him like i'd only text him back
once a day out of obligation because i
thought he was like uh
my boss's friend and one day he just
like
i got bored and started messaging him
and he and i started
dating shortly after that we would text
for months before he and i actually hung
out separately because of the pandemic
he moved to uh cosa mesa
stayed there and i drove down to see him
and in my head i'm like [ __ ]
if he try something yeah i don't know
what i'm gonna do i am
intimidated yes [ __ ] his dong baby
this gorilla
i am so [ __ ] intimidated yeah
i just the entire time we're watching
food videos on this couch like on
youtube
like uh buzzfeed's best 10
three [ __ ] hours in the last like 10
minutes of us hanging out he made a
movie started kissing me and i was so
intimidated i was like okay i got to go
home
i like ran to my car you were previously
with somebody for 10 years
yeah and then the next person who wanted
to date me was a [ __ ] porn star with
this like
mask crazy is that how crazy is that so
weird and that's why
people give me [ __ ] for now they're like
how do you go from being like this nice
girl to only fans and you're dating a
porn star i'm like
first of all this is the [ __ ] most
wholesome person besides like his
sketchy past if you know him yeah he's
the most wholesome person you'll ever
meet all he wants to do is go to home
goods
and [ __ ] work out all day how many
people were you with uh sexually before
your last boyfriend
uh it was a before my boy no it was just
my boyfriend at that time
so this is your second person that
you've been with no so there was a short
amount of time would you hold out a
little bit uh yeah i hold out
okay hold out uh when my boyfriend and i
broke up there was a few months i didn't
tell anybody not even people i worked
with because i didn't want it to be like
a thing on the podcast
and then it came out on the podcast and
at that time
like i had already had like a booty call
because i was like
[ __ ] something yeah so i had this guy
that i was seeing here and there
and we both made it very clear like
we're just here to hook up whatever
and then he ended up catching feelings
so i was like okay peace
we got to go somewhere uh and i started
dating around for a little bit i
[ __ ] in total four people but gave
head to five people
so people people think like i'm like
this big hoe now that i'm just
i'm with a porn star but it's like i
hold out for a little bit but
not that i mean that body count is
pretty [ __ ] low though yeah that's
really like i just did a lot of work in
like three months
yeah you just did you just did some work
in between because that body counts
really [ __ ] low
yeah but it's one of those things i
think because like i'm not only fans and
because like i'm dating a porn star
people think that i'm super
like [ __ ] funny and like super
promiscuous so it was intimidating for
you to hook up this dude because they
talked about his master's yes
and when we were making out i could like
i like saw like the size
of it so it's like it's for real for us
you're like
oh [ __ ] like oh that's the biggest one
you've ever been with
yes but here's the thing a lot of people
make like terrible like shitty like
small
asian dick jokes on the podcast but my
ex-boyfriend has the second largest dick
i've ever [ __ ]
and he's not that far off from my
current boyfriend holy [ __ ] he had a big
dick for a
guy but i didn't know this because he's
the only dick i [ __ ] yeah so you don't
know what you're saying yeah i didn't
know until the next guy after my ex i
was like
huh like oh okay so you were you were
prepped correctly yeah and then it was
like the next guy after him and i was
like
oh my ex had a big dick and i didn't
even know
it did there was some i remember too
when i was in uh uh
when i was in high school i had a homie
it was an asian dude right and people
would always joke about his big dick i
never saw his dick
but when this fool was like you want to
know how big my dick is i'm like no bro
nobody wants
to go show it to you right and this full
in his basketball shorts he had these
baby blue jordan shorts and he just
outlined it i'm like is that a baby arm
what the [ __ ] is that guy basically
maybe i was like what the [ __ ] is that
this guy was like five foot four yeah
and that [ __ ] was like literally if he
just pulled his shorts up a little bit
we would have probably saw the tip
yeah i'm like what what is this how how
do you function you know it's even more
confusing people who are growers
when you're like oh i can kind of
imagine and it just keeps growing and
growing especially like if it's in your
mouth
and it's like you're like oh [ __ ] this
is too much
i i feel suddenly i'm joking i think a
lot of asian girls and dudes are
growers like there's yeah asian news are
growers and then it grows bigger
yeah right that's why like if you saw an
asian dude flaccid you'd think that
he they'd have small things so i saw
this uh documentary
on it was like the uk or some [ __ ] like
that
uh it's like the bbc channel right and
it was literally
this this study of men who
wanted to know it was like a something
about average penis size or something
like that right
and so they were talking about growers
and showers
and at this i'm super young at this
point at this point i thought the
growers shower thing was like a joke
right but there's people who have a big
ass dick
flaccid and when it's a erected it's the
same size
yeah yeah which is shocking which is
weird to me oh [ __ ] that's
it's i've only seen one of them in
person so when i so when i was looking
at and they would on on the bbc special
they would have the guys go erect
because they were
essentially what they were doing was
trying to test out to see if these uh
penis enlargement pills work
if pumps work whatever these different
modalities of getting your dick
bigger is is effective or not yeah and
so they were showing growers and showers
and there was a guy who had a six-inch
dick flaccid
so i assumed that it was gonna go to
nine but it was six flaccid
six hard yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
is that
that's it just like stood up it just
stood up i'm like
oh that's what that is that's the [ __ ] i
think that's why
that that whole like uh asian guys have
small dicks is a thing
because it's like you assume that it's
just that's the dick that you get
because it's a growing yeah but it's a
grower i have a home girl of mine who
specifically doesn't like uh
uh showers because she's expecting she
wants to be the person that makes it
grow
she's like i don't like why because i
want to know that i made that tiny thing
big
yes so she specifically doesn't like
uh show her she likes growers only she
likes the jack and the beanstalk
she wants to be the person that turned
you on to make you hard like that
oh how [ __ ] interesting that's her
requirement
oh wow you know i always thought with
the like little
asian guys have little dick jokes i
always thought that realistically if
this
is real and let's say asian guys do
statistically have smaller dicks
i i thought that that was then paired
with the
thing of asian women having tight
[ __ ] i thought it was supposed to fit
because like
us ethnically as people are supposed to
procreate so like
a small dick is meant for like a tight
[ __ ] yeah i thought that's what it was
[ __ ] are weird though they're all
different sizes too just like
sorry there's like uh like girls who are
bigger than i've hooked up with
like they have can you feel it yes you
can tell when a really
really tight and a cavernous [ __ ] like
it's just a cavernous
cavernous [ __ ] like literally it feels
different
some girls are a little tighter some and
this has nothing to do with asian
mexicans or anything else like that is
this the way your body's about yeah
everybody's built different too
like growing up too because when you
watch like porn and you watch
certain things about women before you
even have sex with anybody yeah it skews
your perception of what the female body
is
so a lot of i used to watch so much more
as a kid yourself
i'm telling you i used to i used to dry
hump pillows
like since i was six years old why are
you so sexually active i don't know it's
just always been like that it's always
been like that
always and i didn't know i had like a
high sex drive or a high libido until
i got out of my breakup with my uh
ex-boyfriend
because all the guys i would date after
that i was like oh you have like a crazy
sex drive and i'm like oh this is just
what i've always known what i've always
known this is just me i thought
really that's so crazy yeah i'm the
opposite i
i have a very low libido really because
um i don't know what it is but i think
that's probably why i've been able to
have so many female friends
because like i don't really care you
know
um it's not like low in this since i
never want to have sex but
i wasn't one of those dudes that
everybody was trying to get laid
always trying to get laid every
conversation was about getting your dick
sucked i didn't care i was playing
guitar
i was trying to do stand-up i was having
guitar yeah i was like doing other [ __ ]
okay john mayer
yeah so i never really cared about that
specifically so
when i remember i was with this one girl
filipino girl and her libido was
[ __ ] high i i legit stopped talking
to her because she wanted to have too
much sex i was exhausted really
too much like every [ __ ] time we met
up she wanted to hook up
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm exhausted your
boy trying to do stand up i'm working
two jobs like i can't do
and then for her she equated affection
with being
sexually desired so oh okay that makes
sense
yeah i couldn't match it i'm like it's
not that i don't want you like you
are very languages are different exactly
but she needed to [ __ ]
all the time and i that's when i
realized like yo i'm actually not
that like sex driven yeah you know i'm
more about conversation
whether a girl can make me laugh if she
if she allows to herself to be
embarrassed she could take a joke this
is the stuff that actually gets me like
turned on
yeah like the actual act of having sex i
can't just [ __ ] when i when you want to
[ __ ] it doesn't work that way
if let's say for example i know people
who get into arguments with their
significant other
and they just [ __ ] it out yeah i can't
do that if we're fighting
i can't either yeah we're fighting get
the [ __ ] away from me like you touch me
i will [ __ ] kill myself oh i'm the
opposite i get mad but if you don't come
to try to like make up with me i get mad
i was like get the [ __ ] away from me
and then two minutes later if he does
leave me alone i look like why are you
getting the [ __ ] away from me i'm over
here like
do you not love me like what is wrong
with you
i gotta bounce i gotta be away i gotta
kick box do something else
i i'm not really about that type of [ __ ]
i just wanna hug
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] so your love
language is physical touch physical
touch yes i think it's because i wasn't
hugged enough as a child
your friends just beat your ass the only
time i get touched with my dad would
suck me in the face
yes thanks dad that's crazy it was my
mom
did you did you um did you always
like need that physical touch all the
time or is it something that um
i think i didn't realize that i needed f
physical touch until i received it like
from a boyfriend
like the moment i kind of got
comfortable enough with my ex
i start to realize like oh i'm one of
those people who like pda
all the time and it's just because
having like a hand on me or like even if
we're sitting across
the couch from each other if like your
leg is touching my leg
i feel like i'm loved i feel like that
physical touch just lets me know like
you're there and you're not gonna leave
i'm physical touch in that sense too so
my love language physical touch is first
but it's not sex
it's like just yeah same it's not
necessarily sex but it's like i need
like your physical warmth presence yeah
like put a foot on me touch my knee or
something
and i'm pretty much [ __ ] good yeah
you know which which for me is really
important that's why i can't do long
distance relationships i need to
physically
be around you not all the time because
i'm like hyper
independent and she's my fiance is also
hyper independent you just need that
like physical touch at some point
at some point right so i don't need her
to be around me 24 7. she has her own
job she has her own friends like a tesla
you got a charger
yeah you know i mean i just need a
little like i don't know rub my head or
something
yeah you know what i mean so i know that
you know we're we're good
so like for her hers is words of
affirmation
so i gotta gas her up all the time like
man you clean that spoon real nice baby
no words of affirmation my whole life
yeah so it's hard for me sometimes like
i have to tell her good job
i was never told a good job as a kid
never my dad
i remember my dad once told me good job
and he i only knew this because we got
into an
argument and he told me this was his way
of saying good job it's like um
he cut you some fruit he didn't beat my
ass that day yeah so
what what happened was uh after i left
ucr i was doing really bad there i went
to community college and well i figured
out
okay i want to do well in school so
during summer school when i was trying
to get more credits to make up for the
ones i failed
at ucr i aced all my classes and my dad
came up to me
and he tapped me in the butt and then i
forgot we got into it that's a lot of
physical affection
though for an asian parent and i was on
the butt i remember we got to this huge
argument and he was calling me stupid or
whatever and i looked at him i was like
you have never ever told me good job
once in your life
and i was like everything that i do at
this point you told me you knew what was
going to make me happy and i followed
your rules and i'm still not happy he
goes
what do you mean i told you good job two
weeks ago i was like when he goes
are you just do your butt i was like you
[ __ ]
that's so cute that wasn't a good job
just say it just say good job he can't
he's like
it's not possible it doesn't work it's
like he watched a american football
movie like this is what they yeah
and it's a good job i have acquired a
small version of that yeah so
i'm only used to saying good job when i
truly believe
you've done something amazing but
sometimes some people just need
a good job for the small victories yeah
and that's what she needs
i'm not used to that and i witnessed it
one time when
um we went swimming at her dad's house
yeah
we're in the pool and mariel is climbing
this thing
it's it's the pool has like this whole
tahitian vibe there's a
there's a slide and all this other [ __ ]
and she's like rock climbing it and
she's like looking at her dad going
dad look at this is a thirty-year-old
woman she like dad look at me
am i doing a good job he's like good job
sweetie i looked at her father i was
like
[ __ ] you this is why i had this problem
because you're mad positive
you're telling her like good job for all
the stuff which is a good thing i'm not
used to that
yeah so now i'm learning to say thank
you a lot more i'm learning to say hey
this is i'm she could do literally [ __ ]
and i'm just
telling her a good job because it makes
her feel good it's important it's cute
so now i'm like and it's good too
because i feel like if i have kids i
should be able to do that too as well
yeah it's almost like prep
for sure i'm not i'm not used to that
[ __ ] dude like i i'm
i'm used to doing stuff because you know
you're supposed to do it oh i
oh my kids are going to go to therapy
for sure dude i almost want my kid to be
gay just so
just like i said listen i love you but
you got to let me make some gay jokes at
you like because daddy loves you and i
love your life
but daddy's daddy this is for me like
i'm like give my kids like
hot dogs all the time you like this
right this is what you like [ __ ] gay
boy
daddy loves you give me a kiss i can't
wait dude like i i feel like i'm
hopefully i'll be a good dad dude i'm
i'm scared like having kids scares the
[ __ ] out of me
same i am so afraid of having kids i
want them but
i'm i think because of my situation with
my ex
i have almost like resented being a
mother
like i don't want to take care of
another thing another person besides
myself
you were you were in an extreme case
though yeah i have i've never
heard of somebody taking on four jobs so
their boyfriend could play games all day
i'm surprised oh my god i can't believe
you didn't murder him
i came close and then and then somehow
you still end up having sex with him
i don't see that happening because how
unattractive is that like you
it's very unattractive and it's not
necessarily like
i thought he was physically unattractive
or anything it's just
oh it's mental everything it's
everything is mental at that point like
every little thing that i used to love
about him then became like oh i [ __ ]
hate this thing
i truly believe that girls have a a
higher capacity to love
because they can find things attractive
about a man that's outside of the
physicality of things
like if you have like a vibe and a
connection with somebody that stuff
though it's very important to be
physically attractive i feel
girls are better at that than men are
yeah where it's like
yeah they might not be the most
physically attractive person but they
make me happy they make me laugh and
that becomes more sexually attractive
than the other things
i feel guys are a little more the
opposite where they say that they do
that
but i mean you could see this in the in
the best way possible is when some of
the most [ __ ] ugliest dudes
catcall women who are way better looking
than them yeah thinking that
i don't know what they think it's like
they're like you don't know what the
[ __ ] i do with that like what would you
do with that bro
you would do nothing with it spell it
out for me yeah tell me tell me what you
were doing
walk up to that person and say something
and they're not gonna do it i think i
see that in that type of case where our
our ability to find somebody attractive
is limited to our physical attractive
attraction towards a woman versus a girl
yeah girls are just better at that [ __ ]
i think so too i asked my fiance on the
podcast i was like
when i was at my [ __ ] fattest like oh
you were big when you guys got together
i was big yo and i didn't know i was big
i thought i was just
i don't know i knew i was big i didn't
know i was big big though because
my self-esteem is mad high so like your
boy was over here like yo i'm
i'm desirable you know i didn't know
this type of [ __ ] and you know when i
was when i was hitting her i was a big
dude
yeah so and she was with dudes that were
rock climbers like physically fit people
i just never took
my size and i also do not even rip the
wall
not even just my size i didn't give a
[ __ ] about what i dressed like looked
like anything i just thought my mouth
did the talking
so it like that you had that confidence
exactly so that's what i'm saying like
women have a higher capacity to find
somebody more attractive yeah if the
if the confidence is there if they have
something going on for them yeah
and so even for her i asked her i was
like is it was there come on be real
like did you really find me attractive
she goes i never actually cared as much
like that's a down-ass [ __ ] because i i
it's pretty amazing because i look at
some of these old photos where
i was so focused on being a comic what i
looked like and everything else didn't
[ __ ] matter to me yeah so
you know at a certain point i got i was
like 280 pounds
like 280 pounds [ __ ] jon jones isn't
280 pounds and he's a heavier i'm
i was i weighed more than francis and
god
you know do you understand like that's a
good way to scale it
yeah and i'm like holy [ __ ] i weigh more
than some of the top heavyweights in the
ufc
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
someone should have gave you a show on
tlc
i don't know let me tell you something
dude like i'm trying to get some brand
deals right now i'm like listen i got 30
more pounds to lose i'll make sure it's
because of your [ __ ] machine
and at this point too now now i'm going
to space peloton what's good yeah
pelican hit me up bro
let me know your boy loses like 30
pounds right now asian lives matter
pelican
i know you don't care about me come on
but yeah when i was
she she still found me attractive yeah
you know despite like physically i
wasn't there
which is kind of and so everything for
her right now is a bonus oh
it's a big bonus i'm like oh this is a
down-ass woman and i really appreciate
that about her yeah
yeah i feel like with uh my boyfriend
his physical his like love language is
touch as well
and so him and i are that disgusting
couple and probably we're always like
hugging up on each other like we're
literally like
we're in line trying to get [ __ ] boba
and like we're hugging straight up
hugging like that [ __ ] uh spirit
woman was like
five minutes just waiting in line that's
not even bad let me tell you something
about this couple that i know right yeah
i love this i love this dude i love his
wife whatever they have a beautiful
family is this
barton geo no no no they're they're very
not much pda
like um they're like lightweight pda
yeah
i knew a [ __ ] couple that
i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not me and my friends
were in a car
and the couple was on my left and to my
right
yeah right so i was in the middle yeah
sitting here and they were like
they were staring at each other through
me i feel like she was looking into my
ear hole to look at his face
the most uncomfortable thing and they're
complimenting each other
from the sides of me and i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] is going on
we get out of the [ __ ] car they come
up they start making out an eskimo kiss
and they're like i missed you so much
because i was in the middle
and they missed each other i hate that
and i love it so much i wish i knew what
it was like to be that in love
oh my god to [ __ ] kill these people
she comes i hate it
i missed you i'm like [ __ ] you were the
same car i was just in the middle
but everywhere they go they're literally
[ __ ] their lips are touching as
they're walking
i'm not even exaggerating i'm literally
talking about i've seen them
walk next to each other and smooch as
they're walking down the street
in k-town i wanted to [ __ ] kill them
i wanted to kill them so bad because it
made everybody so uncomfortable we're
like eating korean barbecue they're
literally making out as we're eating and
we're drinking
throughout the whole [ __ ] night you
guys are our quarters having a good ass
good ass time and they're just like i
love your eyes i love your face oh i
can't do that
i would be so embarrassed to tell like
my significant other like a compliment
like that in public
oh it was like i can't do that they're
like i love the way that you speak
you're so cute oh my god i love and
they're eskimo kissing they're [ __ ]
touching nose tips like christian are
they asian
yes they're both korean what yeah it's
so weird we're [ __ ] what i i just know
unicorns found each other because i
don't mind pda
but you got to be mindful of people
around you like it's a little [ __ ]
does our love make you uncomfortable yes
it does
it [ __ ] does now cut that [ __ ] out do
do it somewhere else
it's just so it just makes my skin crawl
a little bit i don't mind when people
hug up on each other
but they're literally complimenting
they're doing a compliment battle
like i said you love my eyebrows i love
the way you
i love the way your nose looks like
they're doing baby talk disgusting
i love it i want it oh my god
i need it i love the veins on your penis
it looks like an angry baby oh my god
you want to know my favorite part about
uh finally like [ __ ] him and seeing
his dick in person
he has a tattoo of homer simpson right
by his
uh thigh looking at his dick
that's and i got to see it in person
funny dude that's so nice
every single time i'm down there giving
ahead i'm staring at homer
do you have sex every day uh not every
day i'd say like every
few days like two three days okay that's
yeah that's pretty normal well
it depends dude i really depends i know
some people who only have sex like once
a month
um that's like i know they're happy they
just
don't yeah well i know they have kids
though so it's different yeah
kids is different when kids get in the
mix is exhausting if you don't [ __ ] me
and it's been longer then i'd say like
three days i start to think you don't
love me
like straight up you're you're like that
[ __ ] wonderful her love language was
[ __ ] dude
but it's okay because there was a point
in time when
like he and i couldn't have sex for two
weeks because i
had a health issue with my uterus and i
had to go to doctors take medicine
they're like oh abstain from
sex for this amount of times like okay
cool and by i'd say
day six i was begging him for dick
please please don't put it anywhere oh
like do you love me i became so clingy
and so needy because i didn't get dick
wow
i was like i i need something something
that's a lot of pressure
that's a lot there's so much work
i'm exhausted thinking about that yeah
and then suddenly he be and
i started making fun of him like you
little [ __ ]
it's like you know you have a problem
with your uterus right like chill out
for a second
i was like i thought i'm dating a porn
star he's like chill is he is is he also
he needs physical touch like that as
much as you do in terms of like yeah i
think uh
not necessarily sex i think it's the
same thing where as long as i
am touching him usually cuddling he just
needs like physical touch to
let him know that like i'm still here
i think he and i have this weird issue
of like people like
weird abandonment issues from different
things okay so him like he was never
really close to his
family growing up and so he never really
got that love as a child in my opinion
from
what he's told me and so when he had
like cancer as a kid and went away to
prison like he never really saw his
family
oh [ __ ] and it was just one of those
things like i think going through such
traumatic things
so early on in your life over and over
not having a foundation there he just
became
super independent and the moment he and
i got together and he kind of knew like
oh it's safe to let my guard down now
he's just like
hi hello how are you i love me i love
you did you miss me
that's crazy well i mean you found
somebody that kind of gives you what you
need
which is really great yeah damn you're
you're [ __ ] exhausting though
that's exhausting i'm exhausted
people who see me on the podcast or they
know me in my everyday life they're like
oh you're super independent and you
don't
like need much because i'm like [ __ ]
you and then behind the scenes you see
me with my boyfriend the neediest [ __ ]
you'll ever meet
the neediest [ __ ] [ __ ] because like
mary and i are very
he loves him like i i'll like for
example before you came on the podcast
i left that 12 i was kicking it with a
bunch of my friends kickboxing yeah
and i come back i don't want to text her
where i'm at like she just knows that
i'm going to come back eventually
you know but i feel like you're the
opposite no he and i text throughout the
day
he and i live together if i am gone from
the house or he's gone
from the house oh my god like we'll
leave yeah
he'll be at the gym i'm like hi how's
your workout i miss you i love you i
tell him i love you probably 20 times a
day
[ __ ] out of here i need all the love i'm
a little [ __ ]
mush ball [ __ ] [ __ ] like
are you serious yes with your ex
boyfriend too before you know
before i yes but not to this degree i
don't know what it is
the older i get the more like
lovey-dovey i am i'm just like
i would be [ __ ] tired i would just
start so
i go off to him and i like every time i
smell him i feel like there are
endorphins that are released
in my brain so i'll go up and just sniff
behind it you're like
cat dude this is like this is how
[ __ ] i am
needy clingy [ __ ] emotional
i need all of it [ __ ] i need all of it i
think it's because i'm super independent
and every other past in my life
so you're okay i mean you know how to
separate this but with the person that
you're with this is
yeah like when i'm in like my safe zone
i am
[ __ ] i'm a child i'm basically a
child that's what
was your was your mom like that with
your dad or your dad like no they
i always thought that they hated each
other growing up and then
i got to a point when i was older like
oh they
play fight and that's their way of
flirting and so i didn't really know it
for a while it's like they don't even
really love each other yeah whatever
asian parents
my parents play fight a lot too that's
how yeah they play fight a lot and when
i was younger they didn't really have
that like romance or that flirty type of
relationship that they do now
now that all of their kids are kind of
older they don't have much to
they don't have money to worry about the
same way they did when whenever my
sister and i were
younger now they're kind of much more
flirty and touchy and my mom's like stop
don't tell me yeah yeah yeah
i couldn't hear you [ __ ] me later like
hey mom what the [ __ ]
the kids are right i am so inappropriate
with my mom now i don't know what it is
there was a switch that happened
where i started joking around with her
about the stupidest things and now i'll
ask her randomly like mom be honest
do you like in your assing and she's
just like
she's like tayden stop it and then
she'll look over like no i think that's
gross
[Laughter]
like mom you should have you should have
dad eat your ass at least once
a little i don't think he likes it i
don't think i like it it's dirty dude
i i don't like butt stuff but stuff is
not my [ __ ] but stuff is fine i recently
got into it and i feel like butt stuff
is only good
if you're doing it properly you know
what it is man it's like i just never
like even when i was younger and they
would do anal [ __ ] i'm like i don't like
this
like i've never liked watching porn with
with ass [ __ ] just because it comes out
because [ __ ] comes out of it
and let me tell you something like i've
okay like i've i [ __ ] somebody asked
once yeah and it was the worst
experience of my life i just didn't
number one it didn't feel as good i
thought it would
really because it's it's tight at the
sphincter area
that's what that's what it was explained
to me as well because the first time i
did anal was with my ex and he and i
were both trying to experiment
and it felt like someone was shoving a
mag flashlight in my ass
and screamed him like take it out take
it out
so he he took it out he's like i don't
it's not really that good
so i asked him what it felt like he's
like well imagine your finger
and like you put like your finger
through this like crevices
it's like this like there's nothing else
there i was like oh
well what does a [ __ ] feel like he's
like it's like that like it's holding on
it's holding on to it yeah it's like
it's like a warm warm handshake
it's like a glo the ass is a glory hole
essentially right so
what the ass feels like it's tight when
it enters and then after
it's just this nebulous space and
there's just the what is this
unless you're constipated yeah then we
have a little friend dude joe told this
funny ass story about how
he hooked up with this girl she's she's
all around the bed she always loved
getting [ __ ] in the ass
yeah this one said that when he pulled
his dick out there was a piece of [ __ ]
hanging on the tip of his dick
oh my god i know it comes in territory
but i would be [ __ ] mortified
i'm mortified if i knew
my [ __ ] was on the guy's dick i would
never see him ever again
we found out on the podcast through this
guy he's he was uh
he's pretty known as like a like a gay
youtuber who talks about
you know homosexuality and like like
specifically in the sexual sense
yeah and he was giving us a low down he
goes man straight people don't know how
to [ __ ] in the ass or like what do you
mean
he goes there's a whole process that gay
dudes go through before we get [ __ ]
it's like we do we clean we make sure
that it's super it's like
you stick your [ __ ] long ass dick
into a [ __ ] ass there's gonna be [ __ ]
at the end of it
but a lot of people don't know that you
know what i mean and i didn't know that
[ __ ] either i was like
this is gross i don't like this i don't
like this at all
and you know once you try it but that
girl liked anal i just
didn't enjoy it like i it wouldn't feel
good i'm like the point of this is for
this to feel good i think it's more of
the sexual act of doing something
that's different than a vagina that
makes it hot you know what got me into
uh anal what during that like two week
period of not being able to
like do it wait so what ended up
happening i was like okay let's try and
i remember i hated it before but maybe
like if we keep trying it it'll be fine
when it started to hurt i told myself
something that i heard asakira say which
is you got to do something 21 times for
it to be
a habit so i gotta get [ __ ] in the ass
at least 21 times
not the person you gotta try 21 times
for you to [ __ ] enjoy it that sounds
like a [ __ ]
a beaten person's mentality yes uh but i
did that
and by the 22nd day yeah it feels fine
yeah but
i mean his [ __ ] is huge though yes that
[ __ ] is violating the [ __ ] out of you
the body is an amazing thing it adapts
and it is it [ __ ] adapts i just
i don't know that that act is what you
know i don't even like this [ __ ] too
though what like
i don't i remember i got head uh driving
because
uh a girl that i was hooking up with
she's oh that scares me and i couldn't
do it what if we
die and this is how people find us well
i couldn't focus
and i and because i couldn't focus in
the imminent fear of death yeah i kept
on getting hard soft
hard soft i'm like oh you couldn't like
keep it up because i'm really crying
yeah and i'm like oh [ __ ] hard soft hard
stop and i was like i don't enjoy
this actually stresses me out because i
get anxiety yeah i'm like the anxiety's
not helping my dick getting hard i can't
do this and she's like oh you're no fun
i'm like
i feel like i'm gonna die so how do you
expect me to be hard while i do this
we could pull over that's fine but she
liked the whole danger
but that was the girl who really liked
[ __ ] let me tell you what's a lot of
pressure too
this [ __ ] i was the only asian guy that
she's ever been with
everybody else all black dudes oh that's
a lot it was just a [ __ ] ton of pressure
and i just remember because i knew of
her because
she was one of my childhood friends um
sister's friend and so i met her at a
halloween party that they had in their
house and she was dressed up as a
naughty nun
and i said oh [ __ ] right and i just got
out of a serious relationship you need
her to exercise that dick
and i was like this is new and so i just
started hitting on and she was like five
years old to me
okay and at this time i had nothing
going on for me i just i just started
like chopping it up with her next thing
you know
we ended up hooking up and then we were
together for a little bit
terrible relationship by the way it
lasted a month because i found out that
she was kind of nuts
um obviously she also wanted to have too
much sex and i just
didn't like that [ __ ] so for her which
people like you're [ __ ] gay bro
let me tell you something having sex
twice a [ __ ] day when you're working
three jobs
is exhausting when you're working it's
the most exhausting thing you could do
that's the last thing i want to do when
i come home well that's what i'm saying
it's the last you didn't understand
don't touch me yeah i'm like listen i
i'm a full-time student i was trying to
do stand-up
on the side too i had to help my parents
business out i was also working at the
[ __ ] men's warehouse
i was doing a thousand [ __ ] things
like
she just worked her job and then she
would just wait for me all day and i'm
like listen
i'm tired like i just got off doing a
set it's [ __ ] 12 o'clock
i just went out drinking with these
dudes i got whiskey dick i can't [ __ ]
you right now i'm sorry
and that's when i figured out and then
she obviously heard
before we even had sex she i knew her
[ __ ] her her list of black dicks that
she went through and i'm like
oh [ __ ] you know i'm like trying to get
like a slight chub before we start
i was like [ __ ] i'm a grower trust me
just give me some time but she was the
woman that actually
was very honest with me about sexual
acts because
prior to her i've only hooked up with
two other women yeah
first girl uh that i i was with i was a
virgin
i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
i don't know how that [ __ ] works
it's just some [ __ ] that your homies
tell you they don't really give you an
honest look about what it is to to get a
girl off
girls should be giving that advice to me
instead of hearing from these dudes so i
was giving her
terrible dick you know the worst dick
probably she's ever had in her life but
she was also not very experienced either
so we both did so you just didn't know
any better yeah
she wasn't very vocal with me she didn't
tell me what she liked what she disliked
what she enjoyed she was quiet in bed
too yeah super quiet
it wasn't really good sex it wasn't very
good sex on my it's also like if you
guys are
like each other's first you don't really
have anything to go off of i don't even
think i was her first i think she was my
first
oh yeah but she just she like it wasn't
fun
you know and i when you're young too if
it's in a [ __ ] it feels good
you know you're like i got off and i
didn't know that she probably had me she
didn't know how to communicate it to me
yeah and it just didn't work out so the
second person that i was with i'm pretty
sure she got terrible dick too and so
this one like i remember after we [ __ ]
i was like
how was that and she was like man let me
tell you something my [ __ ] heart
shattered
i was like what you mean but she started
talking to me about what she liked and
disliked
and then because of her i started being
more communicative when it came to sex
it's like yo what do you like
what do you dislike not off the bat like
it's a study thing but after we hook up
a bit you kind of get a feel for things
and then it starts to get better but if
it wasn't for her
destroying my heart i don't think i
would have done that with my next
partners
which was something i didn't really
think about because a lot of guys come
in
hearing advice from other dudes about
what they think women like but every
woman's different
just like every dude's different i
didn't know that you can get bad [ __ ]
until i got bad [ __ ]
i was like oh this [ __ ] wasn't great
like she didn't know what she was doing
yeah yeah see i feel like i
i think i have a list and then the list
goes out the window i didn't realize
that until
i'd say like six months ago
because when that uterus thing happened
i he and i were just like making out
having fun
and randomly i didn't i didn't intend
that night on ending with anal but
randomly like i got
so when i get turned on i start saying
wild [ __ ] and i don't
i don't mean it i'm gonna gouge your
[ __ ] eyes out like what
that was one time but we were
getting hot and heavy and it got to a
point where randomly like
something came out of me i said put it
in my ass
and i right when the words left my mouth
i was like you're [ __ ] nuts dude
i was like i didn't mean i don't want it
because only in my head now the rest of
the time i was thinking of a mag
flashlight in my like the first time
because the first time yeah
no no no no and so i literally just like
yeah i was like it's too late now
yeah i have to do it and that's how i
started
you're probably a lot more sexually open
than most people though right like
you're uh
depending on the person that you're with
i think so i think nothing is really off
limits to me
as long as like the person i'm talking
to with isn't weird like some people are
weird about it so i'm less likely
to open up or say some [ __ ] but then if
like someone like is just sitting like
you and i
are and it's comfortable and i'm just
talking like i'm telling you a story
then it's fine
but some people are kind of weird about
it or like some people glorify it into
or fetishize it into something more than
what it is do you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah like that's why that's
when i am less likely to say something
when i know it's gonna get twisted in a
certain way
when for me like it's just sex it's
whatever when when they started doing
the big mood
podcast because i've known those girls
for a very long time yeah i'm very odd
in the sense of like
if i know a girl for a long time
sometimes hearing their sexual escapades
makes me feel weird because it's like
i just don't i've never thought about it
in that type of way you know and the
[ __ ]
gina is over here like i like to be
choked out to like black out
i love gina excuse me what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
she goes i want to see like blood
vessels pop in my eyes
i'm like [ __ ] that's assault like what
are you talking about she goes
she said one time some dude chased her
down and threw an iron at the back of
her house
she's [ __ ] nuts dude i'm like you're
exhausting to have sex with [ __ ] have
to do [ __ ]
they have to stretch and [ __ ] before
they [ __ ] her dude yeah i'm like oh my
god you [ __ ] vietnamese [ __ ] are
insane dude yeah
we all got hit we all got hit and so
that's how you equate love
you have to knock out my two front teeth
and then i might [ __ ] love you
because my parents drama of the war
like i i specifically dated vietnamese
girls
i grew up in sacramento yeah you know
all these girls are vietnamese and
that's like the
only girls that i was uh with for like
almost
since my very first roasting when i was
18 all the way till i was like [ __ ]
like 22. it was only vietnamese girls
yeah and that's all i [ __ ] i even try to
learn vietnamese and do all these things
oh damn
yeah that's a hard language to learn you
know it's not a hard language to learn
so hard language to pronounce
because yes it's very simplified right
like in english you have
you that you're this it's just like one
general word but it has
like an honorific system about who you
say that to in terms of what you respect
age and everything else i think also
like the inflection of certain words
throws people off like some people can't
hear
the inflection on certain things well
that for like the ng sound in vietnamese
is [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] dude
like i've never been able to get that
[ __ ] down but like
learning vietnamese was easier to
understand than it was to speak it
yeah that was the more difficult part
but i the first girl i was with
vietnamese and i [ __ ] loved her to
death
so i wanted i wanted to learn how to
speak vietnamese do all this other [ __ ]
but you know it just didn't work out i
was a loser by the way like i
finally like i i identify she was my
biggest life lesson so
yeah i have identified my value based on
how how
she made me feel so because i felt like
such a loser i didn't feel like i was
worthy of her
that when she left me i was left with
nothing i was like oh i'm not worth
anything because she's an ex boyfriend
yeah that's what it felt like but i was
working though at least you're working
but with her we didn't match nothing
made sense it was she was my best friend
so she was my bet i lost my best friend
and my girlfriend at the same time
that's the hardest part losing
your best friend because like you can
get another boyfriend exactly girlfriend
but then like the person that you have
all these inside jokes with that you
could just kick it with that's the
hardest part
yeah and that's the weird thing too and
i when i i had this very specific moment
where i realized i was such a [ __ ]
loser was when
we split up and i was still doing
everything i could
to gain her attention just to have her
be around
and then there was this moment where she
looked at me she called me annoying and
i was like i'm not [ __ ] annoying
and i it it offended me and when you
find out is things that offend you to
your core
is probably stuff that is issues that
you're dealing with yourself yeah and
when i realized i was a loser i
flipped my whole life i was like what
the [ __ ] who is this girl to me
like we broke up she's not even that
special to me like she was my best
friend but we don't make sense
nothing makes sense about us like yeah
she's on a different path i'm on a
different path
and from then on i decided to take
control of my life i went full-on
stand-up i did full-on comedy
uh i dropped out of college i did
everything and she was probably the best
thing that ever happened to me
because it was it was such a shocking
thing to have somebody
tell you what you were face value and
she never did that before
like she never did that [ __ ] but when
she said i was annoying and obnoxious i
was like you're
right i am [ __ ] annoying i'm over
here begging for your [ __ ] attention
why but on you for seeing that though i
feel like a lot of people
even though they can come to terms in
their head and know like ah yeah i'm
being annoying i'm being obnoxious like
they
then flip it they're like no you're
[ __ ] annoying you're obnoxious like
there's nothing wrong with me and they
almost double down on that
dude 100 and i remember there was a a
flip where she even she realized how
different i was was when
um her her current boyfriend at the time
they they split and she came to my place
and she was like hey me and this guy
split
and i looked at her i was like cool why
are you telling me this
all right and she was like oh i just
wanted to let you know i'm like
i don't [ __ ] care what do you mean
right because i was trying to still be
friends with her but i didn't give a
[ __ ] and i remember she was like yeah
i'm just gonna try to be single for a
bit
i was like is that why you came over to
my place to tell me this i was like
i was like you can't be single it's
impossible for you i was like you're
somebody that likes to fix people so you
look for broken human beings
like me and she was pissed lo and behold
one month later she was in a
relationship with somebody that she was
a
a co-worker with i was like you already
had that person in the back before you
split up with this other guy
yeah cause i know you we were best
friends i know who the [ __ ] you are
but she didn't i think that's when for
her she realized oh like i'm not
i can't come to this guy for whatever i
need now
because she always wanted to have her
cake and eat it too she's not a bad
person it's just
that's who she is like she you were an
emotional 7-eleven
yeah 100 whenever she needed me there i
was there
and i felt good that i could be that
person for because i didn't value myself
i didn't value who i was who i can't
what i cared about
and i was specifically a loser because i
chose to be
because i felt like i didn't deserve
success i didn't deserve greatness
because it was based on how she made me
feel so you're happy with the scraps
i was 100 happy with it i was like hey
i'm gonna
be with this woman for the rest of my
life i'm okay when she left me
rock bottom rock bottom i started moving
up i was like i'm gonna do stand-up
and i don't give a [ __ ] if whether it
does bad or not and that was hard for me
i have anxiety
like i had a major anxiety and i still
did stand up
because she taught me that there were
things about myself that i hated that i
wanted to change
so bad no matter how it made me feel i
wanted to change it
because i just hated being a loser i
hate it i [ __ ] hated it once you
realize you're a loser
everything about you you want to change
i have anxiety
i'm going to do stand up because i'm
gonna face that [ __ ] fear
i don't like talking to people i'm gonna
start talking to people because i need
to face that [ __ ] fear yeah and it
was
it was hard for me for a lot of the
times but people don't understand they
go
oh you speak to people so so well now
well that took practice yeah it took a
lot of practice
my dad used to beat my ass because i
couldn't [ __ ] order fast food from
from a restaurant because i was so
nervous to talk to new people oh really
how old were you
how old i was like 20. like i i couldn't
even do that 20.
i had i would've had mad anxiety yeah
and i started doing st and i was
dealing with this anxiety while i was
trying to stand up when i was 16. but i
couldn't even order food at a [ __ ]
fast food restaurant
because i i was so nervous about
everything and people who have anxiety
one of the things that we do a lot is we
try to overlearn about a subject
so we don't feel embarrassed yeah we we
research all this other stuff
so when it comes to a topic we want to
know everything so in case like we sound
stupid we don't want to do that
so when i would go to new restaurants i
would never order things i didn't know
because i wanted to be safe knowing
these type of things and i had to deal
with this anxiety
every time i did stand up i was the same
way but then i
would [ __ ] up and the moment i had to
talk about it
i i was blanked [ __ ] god damn it
i studied three hours it's the worst
feeling ever so
stupid oh my god and i feel like a dumb
ass afterwards i study some more
i'm replaying this conversation in my
head like i could redo it
i would do stand up sometimes and i
would blank out and i would go home and
i think
i would just lay in my bed like you
[ __ ] idiot
just be so [ __ ] mad my first audition
ever
i i auditioned in in los angeles for
this role for like a very serious role
but me being a dumbass for some reason i
read it as a comedic role
i didn't know it was like your brain
just like read it that way as a comedy
and it was like for ncis for like a
murder
and i read it and then director looked
at me she goes that was a very
interesting take
i was like can you try it like this and
i read and for some reason it was like i
was reading the script for the first
time i'm like
this is not for a comedy and i didn't
know how to read it and i went into my
car
i [ __ ] laid down the seat and i
[ __ ] went
you [ __ ] idiot i was mortified dude i
[ __ ]
hate auditions i hate auditions
[Applause]
that was scabbed over i don't care i'll
go into an audition i don't give a [ __ ]
auditions have single-handedly been the
reason why i got out of acting i was
like i hate it
really i hate auditions and i still it
was around the time i started getting
into podcasts where
i was like this is so much better than
sitting around on a set
or like in a theater rehearsing waiting
around this is so much [ __ ] fun and i
never looked back but i
hate auditions hate it hate it hate it
it's a skill
it's a skill it's definitely a skill i'm
one of those people where
if i'm cast in something the day of and
when i actually perform it's different
from my audition
i psych myself up so much during
auditions where i'm like [ __ ]
this this this and then i blink yep i'm
like [ __ ] everything goes out the door
some of that's why people see they when
they see some actors who go on and they
get these roles
they're not great actors yeah but
they're a better auditioner than you
they impressed in that room so they got
the role
yeah so some of the best actors that i
know sometimes they don't book well
because the audition part is the part
that doesn't get them through the door
but i
know that they'll kill it if you give
them the [ __ ] opportunity
yeah and that's the hard part like
everything's a [ __ ] craft man i'm the
worst auditioner on earth dude
i [ __ ] hate it like when you audition
you have to have a multitude of
different outfits
to match that role you have to come in
and i just i just don't give a [ __ ]
enough
i love podcasting i could wear these
slippers i got these sweats on i don't
[ __ ] care
but when you're on audition you're there
to impress cause it's their money and
it's their time
i [ __ ] hate it i also felt weird
about going into auditions because at
usc they always
made it seem like you had to fit a very
cookie-cutter version of what an actor
is supposed to be
because it's a liberal arts [ __ ]
artsy
fartsy school so everyone was very like
woke and very uh pc
and very afraid of saying anything that
was too
edgy yeah it felt like i'm i'm not
somebody who
like can just kind of
pretend to be like a certain way like hi
my name is kat and this like i just
wasn't that cookie cutter version of
like what
usc said this is how you book [ __ ] and i
would try to be that version of it
auditions and it just felt [ __ ] gross
i would go in i'm like
it was like a version of myself and that
i disassociate like who the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ]
yeah yeah who is that vision this
audition room who the hell
yeah is that and who said that this was
okay
i mean that's good that you found that
out early on because a lot of people try
to push themselves into a mold
just because they said that they were
going to do it yeah but you find out new
things about yourself all the time i
thought i wanted to do stand-up for the
rest of my life and
turns out i don't even like standing
that much yeah like i i still do it
because i have like an urge or an itch
to do it here and there
but i don't it doesn't make me happy and
i had to accept that
i mean it was like a few years ago i i
did um i did the uh
what's the place in irvine [ __ ] uh
irvine spectrum
no no it was uh improv the improv we
i went there did great and
didn't feel anything i was like oh that
didn't make me feel good like it was
just like oh cool i made people laugh
and then i walked off stage and i was
like and that was the first time my
buddy clearly saw me do stand-up and he
was like dude you're [ __ ] funny like
i didn't know you did
i was like dude i just standing still
16. and i went up there and then i left
and i didn't feel good i'm like oh did
you used to get like a
validation from it before i used to i
used to get a high off of it like when
you
kill a set it made you feel really good
and then
the set felt good and i just felt okay
about it and i'm like oh this isn't my
joy anymore
like this used to really make me happy
and i found out that i can get that same
feeling from doing a podcast
it doesn't have to be on stage it could
be through film it could be through
anything else
so the thing that i enjoy is affecting
people's life in a positive way
whether whether people agree or disagree
with that that's just what i feed off
it doesn't have to be stand-up it could
be food yeah it could be food where i
create these businesses people walk away
and they walk away with a smile
i found that out when i did saucer for
the first time when i
was sitting at that store people would
eat oh the one k town yeah that was so
[ __ ] good
i know it [ __ ] oh god well now i have
a new one coming up so
they um yeah people would eat the soft
serve and i saw them smile and that [ __ ]
filled up my heart it made me feel
really good you're a nation dad that's
what it is you're an asian dad
i'm like they enjoyed myself service
yeah
i'm like look at that they they enjoyed
the soft serve and it made me happier
than doing stand-up and i'm like uh
stand-up might be something that i'll
always do
but i'll do it for fun it's not going to
be a career yeah you know who knows i
say this now it might change because
stand up i could do it when i'm 40 50
years old it doesn't matter dude there's
not like a
time stamp on it exactly so i can always
come back to it you know same with
acting for me i just like i like it but
i don't think i like it or
love it enough to pursue it actively i
see some of my friends
who i had in usc like
basically went through this program with
and
they are still trying to go down that
route because they love it so much and i
just look at them like i don't have that
i don't love it that like i can't and i
can't fake it i felt like i was just
wasting time
and trying to convince myself like oh
you still like this you just need to try
harder or fall in love with
it again but it's not it's not it just
wasn't for me
yeah that's not how i mean it was just a
way for me to get out of san jose and i
came to terms with that
and you know what acting too is so hard
because there's such a slim chance that
you'll be successful
yeah you know you have to really love
this grind and people who get on tv
shows here and there doesn't mean that
they've made it like there's
a few like they get paid for that day or
two they get their day rate
reoccurring cast members or they get a
stipend yeah and they may not get
another job for the next year or two
i had a friend of mine who came on this
podcast she was talking to me about how
uh her friends from back at home were
like i saw you on this tv show you made
it and she's like [ __ ] i'm living in
this studio [ __ ] apartment with three
people
what makes you think i made it like i
got this check cool it was like whatever
40 50 gs
now that has to last me for this whole
year because i haven't booked anything
in the last eight months
that's the crazy part about acting that
i think a lot of people
don't realize is that just because you
see somebody
who's booked maybe like a reoccurring
part on
this tv show and they got like one
really big check
that doesn't mean that you're gonna have
longevity in this career
yeah it does not give you any sort of
financial stability
at all and even trying to get into the
union as a [ __ ] [ __ ] about itself
and you
you don't have anything to kind of cover
yourself with
in terms of like health insurance and
it's wild i just i did i didn't love it
enough to
put up with all that other stuff like i
can work a regular [ __ ] job
get all these regular benefits get a
401k
and i will be perfectly happy just as
happy as
if i was on a show and getting the same
thing it's just
that's how i told my dad i was i was so
nervous about it and i talked to my mom
she's like i don't see why not like i
was a coffee shop girl even though like
your dad and i are really conservative
at the end the day like you got to make
your money how you make your money as
long as you're okay with yourself you
can look yourself in the mirror
like that's that's all that matters like
i i don't think
i would like you to go out and like do
nudity or anything but like that's up to
you and i told her like i don't think
i'm good with nudity either but
i'm gonna do it to the extent that i'm
comfortable with
but i i just i i don't have the like
little push to
finally do it my mom told me go talk to
your dad see what he says that sounds
like oh [ __ ] okay
so i went up to my dad i was like hey
dad i have this business opportunity
that i have
how [ __ ] funny the way you phrased it
dude yeah i was like this business
the [ __ ] out of here that's hilarious i
was like so there's this thing called
only fans and he's like okay what is it
i'm like
you know instagram he's like yeah it's
like it's like instagram but you have to
pay to see everything
like okay so people want to see pictures
of my feet
and he's like oh yeah why wouldn't you
do i was like well people also want to
see other stuff and i'm like willing to
do other stuff he's like okay but
what's the other stuff it's like well
me in a bikini he's like well you're at
the beach other people see you in bikini
like me in my bra and underwear he's
like our family is damn near a nudist
family
i've been walking around in a speedo
around the house since you were [ __ ]
your mother was a hooker before i met
her
you came out it's okay man he's all
happy about it yeah he's like yeah
how much money are you making it's like
i could retire you pretty soon
okay be my guest well i didn't even
think i was gonna make that much money
off of it i thought it was just gonna be
like an extra
maybe like a extra grand or something
yeah and so when i did that
i made a lot more that's crazy and uh i
told my dad
and when my dad found out he was like oh
my god that's crazy and now i'm
buying him a corvette i want to be a
girl so bad
mine is the periods experience can i can
i not trade
that's the trade-off you guys give
[ __ ] peers but you could get people
to want to see you
[ __ ] naked so bad yeah that's great
but the wild thing is that like
now people who used to [ __ ] with me are
so angry at me for that
why because on one hand it's people like
oh i'm disappointed in you
i thought you were like this innocent
girl
like who wasn't gonna show off her body
now you're
uh almost like damaged goods and then
there's another
section that's mad at me because it's
like how dare you monetize off of us
sexualizing you for the last three years
i was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about back when i was conservative as
[ __ ] and wearing like tank tops and a
sweater if i had like this much cleavage
out
the comments would just be like did you
zoom in i zoomed in
get like [ __ ] out of here it came up on
a podcast but girls were talking about
oh is it pockets or jk news but the
girls have like a whole reddit section
about them
i haven't read a section about me i see
that's what i'm saying it's crazy so
it's like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you guys sexualized them anyways
now i'm talking about this reddit [ __ ]
is [ __ ] hilarious like they're
there's people like superimposing their
oh
told me about the or she has deep fakes
or like jesus i'm pretty sure all those
girls have [ __ ] deep fakes dude like
they they're like super imposing their
face on [ __ ]
it's like who the [ __ ] told me this
i think one of the girls told me there's
like dudes like jacking off to their
photos and
having a photo of just their face or
some [ __ ] of them jacking off like what
the [ __ ] is this
weird reddit world about some guy sent
me a dm
it was a video of him he uh put his
fleshlight in between his couch so it's
like
stuck right there and he starts [ __ ]
it and he does the video like
this is what uh you make me want to do
and then he's like [ __ ] his
flashlight like that he's
smooshed in between his couch cushions
that's crazy i have on my phone right
now get
the [ __ ] because when people ask me like
what's one of the wildest things that
people send you i'm like this is a good
way to start off this is what i get this
is why i don't read my videos easy man
like that whole reddit world too like i
don't know i don't really go on reddit
yeah
it's just a little it's hard for me to
navigate i'm not i don't i don't know
why but it's not a very clean ui
and it bothers me it's like my ocd yeah
it's like though it's almost like the
old blog it's like a forum
it bothers me i can't i can't be on that
website it's just a particularity that i
have yeah
when they were talking about that that
that that uh the
whole reddit section it's just it's
crazy to me it's
crazy like uh oh tiff was telling me on
this podcast years ago they have a fan
fix
or fanfic fan fiction yes that's what uh
fifty shades of grey turned out to be it
was a fanfic of twilight
get the [ __ ] out of here really twilight
light was an inspiration for fifty
shades of grey it was a fanfic
and it got so popular that it became a
book and now movie
what the [ __ ] wild dude and then when uh
i was talking about
fanfics either it was on the podcast or
jk news people who are upset that like
fanfics aren't only sexual blah blah
blah it's some i was like
get out of here dude get the [ __ ] out of
here dude it's sexual you know you ain't
got a front bro
you're not a [ __ ] that's just mad sexual
dude you're talking about these
these weird scenarios i won't say weird
it's just these scenarios that you
desire out of these people which i guess
is fine
but there's a community for it and it's
actually pretty popping on reddit
yeah i can't imagine that [ __ ] though
that's that's just [ __ ] crazy
reddit triggers me really yeah read it
[ __ ] it because fighter and the kid has
the most
toxic [ __ ] reddit page that i've ever
seen and it's one of those things where
i started working for them i didn't know
what it was somebody sent it to me i saw
it was like jesus christ this
is like actually [ __ ] scary and now
anytime
because i was handling the social media
stuff anytime something
with reddit popped up i'm always like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i don't want to look at
it
it's almost like watching a beheading
video in my the fighter and the kid
thing is real man like
um like brendan's like they they [ __ ]
cycle analyze
everything that he does everything and
it's never that deep
yeah it's like he's just talking dude
like and also too like we tell so many
stories on this [ __ ]
we change small things here and there
but sometimes we explain it more for
they're like well they said this last
time it's like yeah we explained it a
little further
it's like yeah pretty much the same
story or are you shorting the story for
exactly dude like it's not it's not that
[ __ ] deep
but you know brendan too like he's he
he's polarizing i will say it's a good
problem to have though
it's a good problem to have because you
make money off of it yeah and people are
talking about them for a [ __ ] reason
but
like the fighter and the kid thing like
it's it's crazy they they that's their
community
they want to talk about something that
they have a common um whether it's good
or bad yeah they enjoy and there's good
stuff too when they have a dope guest
and they like the chemistry
it's a pretty interesting community yeah
for me i'm just like i just don't want
to see it it could be there and live on
the internet i just
don't want to see it so anytime people
try to send it to me i'm like please
don't
we all got [ __ ] reddit people just
trashing us
all the time i'm okay with it i mean
that's that's just the ener
that's the stuff that i knew that i was
getting into it's like when
once i'm out in the public eye
everything that i say is going to be
scrutinized
so it doesn't matter it's like well i
remember somebody coming at me saying
like you once said this you were so i
was like yeah i changed my mind
that's nothing people think you can't
change your mind yeah like you can't
just form another opinion with different
with different information that has been
presented to you
yeah or like you aged out of something
where you're like oh i don't think like
that anymore yeah i completely changed
my mind what's the problem
because then the fight ends and they
have nothing else to like no leg to
stand on they're like oh well this is an
issue you don't want to fight
yeah it's like what are you [ __ ]
perfect dude i don't know what the [ __ ]
i was saying some [ __ ] and i thought i
was right and it turns out i had a
conversation with somebody else and i'm
like
i don't think like that way anymore yeah
and it's a problem it's everybody wants
to be perfect the first time and it
never works out that way
yeah there's no there's no forgiveness
anymore like there really is
there's no empathy from anybody oh dude
and but that's the funny thing
too because they think that they're the
empathy generation but you're not you're
looking to bring people down to bring
yourself up and it never works out well
for that way
because it doesn't make you feel good at
the end of the day you have to keep
doing that over yeah
and over and over and it's exhausting
man
just like i don't know man like
everybody can change like as
long as they show it and even if you
don't show it i don't care about you
enough dude
yeah i don't [ __ ] care you can't
police what everybody does
because change shouldn't be like a
performance yeah it's not something that
i need to
show everyone like hey guys i've changed
i'm good now right
like it's not for you like i'm even
telling people to stop like there's
personal friends that i know that have
the exact opposite feeling how i have
about certain things that are very uh
polarizing like blm i know somebody
that's a relative that [ __ ] hates blm
and my thing to them i just had a
conversation with them i was like
honestly
you're allowed to have your opinion i
get it i'm not mad at you i'm like
but i will i just say my piece i go you
have an opinion about a group of people
that you don't know yeah you're a dude
that only grew up around asian people
you have some white friends here and
there you've never had a conversation
with a black person never been a part of
their community but you want to tell
them how to live their life
so at that point we just leave it at
that and we're still good friends
yeah you could have your opinion about
that some people can't do that though
some people want to fight and i just
tell them like hey just don't bring that
[ __ ] around because it's going to get
under my skin yeah but other than that
we cool bro
like i i'm i said my piece if it doesn't
change your mind that is what it is
just uh just don't be disrespectful and
then we gotta leave it at that
and he doesn't and he's mad respectful
about it and that's all
see that's the best way to do it but
then a lot of people don't
it's almost like i feel like
a lot of people do this [ __ ] as a
performance to show
other people like hey i'm on the good
side or hey i'm a rebel
it's one or the other it's like why does
everything have to be a [ __ ] fight
i just don't care anymore now yeah like
i'm exhausted it's for our sanity
because imagine if we had to care about
every little thing it's hard man i just
started reading about the stuff that's
happening in the [ __ ] middle east
right now
and there's so much to read about it's
it's like dream every time i see one of
those like little kids crying on this
video
i [ __ ] cry i will bawl my eyes out
people are asking me to talk
i don't know what to talk about like
there's so much and it's so history deep
you can't have me speak about that on
this podcast because i don't know what
i'm talking about
yeah that's something that i'm going to
stay off of like i'll like
everybody has a side on this one and i
just i just don't want them to feel
pain but how dumb is that for me to say
you know so i just kind of stay away
from it yeah
well that that wraps up damn we've been
doing this for two [ __ ] hours
what holy [ __ ] that went by so fast that
was amazing oh that's fun
okay well thanks for having me yeah i
mean thank you for coming on that was a
dope [ __ ] podcast
uh where can they find you that's your
only fans baby
uh only fans slash t3i three e's and an
n it's the same as my instagram handle
that's dope well that's genius brain
podcast every thursdays and sundays and
we'll see you all next time
bye peace